Ja, herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr.34.
Ich hoffe, du hast es jetzt nicht erzählt.
Nein, habe ich nicht. Bei uns heute zu Gast im Studio ist Rop Gonggrijp.
Hallo.
Nachdem wir nun so lange schon keine Sendung mehr hatten und uns natürlich dessen bewusst sind, dass wir das Publikum nicht gerade glücklich gemacht haben, wollen wir heute mal so ein bisschen über das große Ganze reden, also den State of the World, was eigentlich gerade so passiert und warum und wo die ganze Sache hier hinführen wird. Und da ist Rop natürlich irgendwie ein guter Ansprechpartner als wohl informierter Mensch. Wir entschuldigen uns natürlich irgendwie für die ganzen Unannehmlichkeiten, die dadurch entstanden sind, dass wir irgendwie so lange keine Sendung gemacht haben, aber es gab die üblichen Probleme, wir mussten zu viel arbeiten.
Alles Franks Schuld, wenn ich mich fragne.
Also Fefe war wieder monatelang in irgendwelchen feindlichen Staaten unterwegs, auswärts, um sich für Geld zu verdingen. Ich hatte auch zu viel zu tun. Es war Sommer, aber jetzt sind wir wieder zurück. Gut, wo fangen wir dann eigentlich an? An welcher Ecke? Fangen wir mit der Ukraine an, wo es am nächsten dran ist?
Naja, der Landesverrat ist noch näher, oder?
Der Landesverrat ist noch näher, genau.
Ja, naja, also es ist ja alles so ein bisschen überraschend, was dann plötzlich für Paragrafen, die seit vielen Jahren tot galten, da aus der Kiste gezogen werden.
Vor allen Dingen nicht nur Paragrafen, sondern tatsächlich auch so Struktur. Also ich meine, dieser Generalbundesanwalt, die Behörde mit allem, was dazugehört, wurde ja geschaffen zu RAF-Zeiten. Also rote AME-Fraktionen, also die Institution gab es schon früher, aber damals wurde halt gerade diese politische Weisungsbefugnis und irgendwie alles, was damit zu tun hat, gemacht und ausgefeilt und denen auch quasi eine relativ starke Unabhängigkeit gegenüber dem Rest der Justiz gegeben. Und dass die natürlich vorher benutzt wurde, um nicht gegen die NSA und die Bundesregierung bei der Beihilfe der NSA zu ermitteln, aber dann jetzt natürlich gegen die Leute eingesetzt wurde, die versuchten, da so ein bisschen Licht in die Sache zu bringen, ist dann natürlich schon sehr spannend. Also das war schon aus meiner Sicht so ein bisschen der Backlash des Deep State.
Also ich weiß nicht, man muss das ein bisschen auch differenzierter betrachten, als es in den Medien war, denn Ermitteln ist so fast ein Automatismus. Also auf der einen Seite freut mich sehr, dass es jetzt allgemein Wissen ist, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft weisungsbefugt ist und insbesondere auf der anderen Seite.
Weisungsgebunden.
Weisungsgebunden, Entschuldigung, weisungsgebunden ist. Das wussten vorher nicht alle. Das ist sehr erfreulich, dass das jetzt bereits bekannt ist. Auf der anderen Seite, was hier ja geschehen ist, sind Ermittlungen aufgenommen worden vom Generalbundesanwalt. Und das einzige, was anders ist, der macht ständig irgendwelche Ermittlungen. Auch bei Merkel-Handy hat er Ermittlungen gemacht.
Nee, nee, da hat er Vorermittlungen gemacht.
Na gut, also das ist ein interessantes Konspekt, aber sehr wichtiger Unterschied.
Weil Ermittlungen bedeutet ja, dass tatsächlich irgendwie die Strafprozessordnung angewendet wird und also Maßnahmen nach dieser Strafprozessordnung durchgeführt werden, was unter anderem halt eben doch abhören und observieren und erwarten und bedeuten kann. Während Vorermittlungen nur heißt, er will die Zeitung lesen.
Ja, also es ist noch ein bisschen diffiziler im Einzelnen. Aber was ich sagen will, dass er Ermittlungen aufgenommen hat, kann man ihm meines Erachtens nicht so doll vorwerfen, wie das jetzt geschehen ist. Obwohl es natürlich ein Skandal ist, dass wir gegen Journalisten ermitteln, wenn sie ihre Arbeit tun. Aber dass er die Ermittlungen aufnimmt, ist noch relativ normal. Er hätte sie halt sofort wieder schließen müssen. Und das ist auch geschehen, aber leider erst nachdem die Bevölkerung auf die Parikaten gegangen ist.
Na was heißt denn sofort? Ich meine, das war ja lange Zeit dazwischen. Die haben ja die Mitteilungen am Ende erst gemacht, weil sie sonst halt in Verjährungsprobleme geraten wären.
Ist damit nicht aber erst offiziell die Ermittlungen überhaupt losgetreten?
Nee, damit ist...
Ach, das heißt, die haben vorher schon...
Ja, das liegt doch schon Monate lang. Das liegt doch schon seit April oder so was.
Ich dachte, das waren alles die Vorermittlungen, die seit Monaten liegen.
Also der eigentliche Skandal ist natürlich halt irgendwie dieser Chef des Verfassungsschutzes, der ist halt für notwendig, gegen Journalisten ermitteln zu lassen und der sowieso also auch mal ganz oben auf die Liste der Leute gehört, in diesem Skandal zurücktreten müssen.
Der hätte da gar nicht erst hingedurft. Aber auf der anderen Seite muss ich sagen, mein Weltbild und mein Modell, mit dem ich die Politik modelliere, ist, dass da lotterkleine Rädchen im Apparat sind und jeder versucht, möglichst seinen Arsch zu bedecken.
Maaßen ist ein richtiger, schreibt es, steht da. Maaßen war derjenige, der als die Amis gesagt haben, wir haben ja noch diesen Kroner, was wollte er denn wieder haben, der halt in so einer Blackside saß.
Das Gutachten geschrieben, was sie gesagt haben.
Und Maaßen hat halt gesagt, ja pff nee, so Asyl kriegt er hier eigentlich nicht mehr, weil der war sechs Monate ja nicht im Land.
Genau.
So ein Typ ist der Maaßen.
Ist kein Sympath, keine Frage. Allerdings passt das noch, also der Kroner hat es nicht, aber passt die Landesverratsanzeige, die passt in mein Weltbild von, also was er damit von sich abfänden wollte, ist, dass in drei Jahren jemand fragt, wieso hat denn hier keine Anzeige erstattet. Und da ist eigentlich noch nicht viel mit vergangen, so eine Anzeige zu erstatten.
Bloß er hat halt nicht nur Anzeige gegen Unbekannt zur Ermittlung von dem gestellt, sondern sie haben diese Gutachten machen lassen, um explizit gegen Erzpolitik vorzugehen. Und das ist aus meiner Sicht eben wirklich ein gezielter Angriff des Deep State gegen dieses ganze System von Berichterstatter und Leaking. Worum es ihnen da ging, war offensichtlich und klar, zu versuchen, zukünftige Leaker abzuschrecken.
Also ich glaube einfach, dass das eine große Angst ist vor dem Kontrollverlust, dass sie plötzlich in Zeiten von Wikileaks sehen und von Snowden, dass ihre ganzen Deep State geheimen Akten nicht mehr so sicher sind, wie sie dachten. Und dass jetzt einfach ein Backlash kam, dass sie gesagt haben, okay, da müssen wir jetzt mal ein Exempel statuieren.
Also die interessante Frage ist, ob ihnen das gelungen ist, ob diese Ermittlungen und der Skandal darum dazu geführt haben, dass zukünftige Leaker sich abgeschreckt fühlen?
Das glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, weil man bei WikiLeaks, also jetzt nicht im deutschen Kontext, aber im weltweiten Kontext sehen kann, dass die Snowden-Geschichte keinen abgeschreckt hat, obwohl es dem ja wirklich weltweit sehbar Scheiße ging. Monatelang da am russischen Moskauer Flughafen gefangen und jetzt zu KGBs Gnaden an irgendeinem Landhaus untergebracht und irgendwie kann nur per Videokamera mit anderen Leuten kommunizieren. Also das hat ja auch nicht genug abgeschreckt, als dass wir jetzt nicht dauernd irgendwelche neuen Leaks hätten von irgendwelchen Freihandelsabkommen und so. Was ja auch, wenn man sich anguckt, was da für Geheimhaltungsbullshit mit irgendwie Leseraum in der US-Botschaft und so am Start ist, das ist ja fast noch krasser als irgendwelche Geheimdienstsachen zu liegen. Und da sehe ich sehr erfreut, dass das offenbar nicht abgeschreckt hat.
In den 90ern hat der Generalbundesanwalt auch ermittelt gegen die ganze Vorstand von Access for All. Der Internetprovider, der ich da mal...
Stimmt, das ist ja auch den Spaß.
Erzähl doch mal.
Da hatte jemand, ein User bei uns, hatte auf seiner Homepage eine Ausgabe.
Was uns war?
Uns ist Access for All, der Internetprovider in Amsterdam. Und die User haben da Homepages. Und das war zu dem Zeitpunkt, Mitte der 90er Jahre, war das noch nicht so bekannt, was das denn war. Und da hatte da eine Ausgabe vom Zeitschrift Radikal getan. Und in diese Ausgabe ging es darum, Zugverkehr zu stoppen im Rahmen dieser ganzen Wendland-Proteste gegen Kastortransporte, also Atommülltransporte. Da waren also gewisse Hinweise drauf, wie man dann Züge stoppt und so weiter und so weiter. Und diese Ausgabe von Radikal war in Deutschland verboten. Konnte man aber in Holland einfach im Buchladen oder Zeitschriftenladen kaufen. Weil bei uns war das nicht verboten. Es hat also ein User bei uns auf seine Homepage getan. Und dann haben wir also Telefon bekommen, ja blockieren sie das bitte, weil es in Deutschland illegal ist. Da haben wir gesagt, naja, wenn wir das machen, dann kommt morgens Saudi-Arabien und möchte auch alles blockiert haben, wo Titten sichtbar sind oder wo. Das können wir leider nicht machen. Und dann haben die zwei Sachen gemacht. Die haben angefangen uns zu blockieren, also unsere IPs zu sperren. Darauf sind dann 50 mehrererseits weltweit hochgebracht worden. Dann war plötzlich diese radikale Ausgabe überall im Netz. Und die haben Ermittlungsverfahren gegen uns wegen Verdachts des Werbens für terroristische Vereinigungen in Tateinheit mit Anleitung zu Straftaten und öffentlicher Erbilligung von Straftaten. Und dann haben wir so nach Jahren dann so einen Einstellungsbrief, die gerade auch Netzpolitik empfangen hat, haben wir bekommen. Aber so dieses Kontrollverlust, hey, wir hatten hier mal eine funktionierende Zensur. Das geht jetzt nicht mehr. Erst mal versuchen, diese Kontrolle durch Einschüchterung zurückzubekommen. Das ist schon etwas, was wir kennen.
Was mich halt frage ist, wenn man sich jetzt so die Zeitung anguckt, so Zeit zum Beispiel, hat er da gerade einen ziemlich guten Run mit jeder Menge interessanter Dokumente. Und die gehen es ja auch halbwegs professionell an. Also die haben sich halt so einen Leaking-Briefkasten eingebaut in ihre Webseite und bekommen da offensichtlich auch Dokumente. Und sind jetzt auch dazu übergegangen, halt eben nicht nur aus den Dokumenten zu zitieren, wie alle anderen, sondern noch die Original Dokumente zu bringen. Also wie zum Beispiel diesen Vertrag, mit dem der Verfassungsschutz XQSQR bekommen hat und damit mit Daten bezahlt hat. Und ich glaube ja, dass das Hauptproblem, was die haben, die Medien ist, dass sie nicht das Gefühl haben, dass es noch was hilft. Und damit möglicherweise auch die Likert nicht das Gefühl haben, dass es wirklich was hilft. So, weil letztendlich haben wir...
Spielt das bei Medien eine Rolle, ob das was hilft? Ich dachte, da geht es hauptsächlich darum, im Moment so Existenzkampf irgendwie, das schafft Einschaltquoten, das verkauft mehr Zeitung.
Click-Through-Rate.
Ja, meinst du wirklich, die machen das um die Welt zu vermissen? Also der einzelne Redakteur, aber die Zeitung noch ein.
Das ist die interessante Frage. Wahrscheinlich bringt es nicht mehr Click-Through als eine Katzenbilderstrecke.
Das glaube ich nicht, weil die Redakteure und die Chefredaktion bewertet ihren Erfolg nicht nur an Click-Through, sondern auch daran, ob sie es schaffen, die öffentliche Debatte zu lenken. Und das hat eindrucksvoll geklappt bei diesem Thema.
Aber trotzdem, zumindest ein paar von den Chefredakteuren haben ja auch noch den Anspruch zu sagen, wir sind vierte Gewalt und wir möchten gerne, wenn wir halt so einen fetten Skandal haben, dass es dann auch jemals zurücktritt.
Gut, das ist mit Merkel nicht zu haben.
Na gut, aber keine Ahnung mit Maaßen oder mit irgendeinem der anderen Verantwortlichen spezifisch in dieser Ex-Giesgrohe-Geschichte oder wer auch immer damals im Bundeskanzleramt verantwortlich war, das abzunicken. Und das passiert halt nicht mehr. Und der Grund dafür ist zum einen, dass die, glaube ich, verstanden haben in der Politik, dass Aussitzen Macht bedeutet, weil in dem Moment, wo die Medien nicht mehr daran gewöhnt sind, dass sie mit einem relativ einfachen Story oder einem einfachen Skandal jemanden wegschießen können, hören sie vielleicht auf damit. Oder es bewirkt halt nichts mehr. Und zum anderen ist es, glaube ich, auch ein Problem dessen, dass sie einfach Personalmangel haben. Also wenn du dir anguckst, gerade so eine Innensicherheitspolitik.
Die Zeitung jetzt oder die Politik?
Also gerade eine Innensicherheitspolitik. Also nehmen wir mal an, Demisier müsste zurücktreten. Nur mal so als ultrahypothetischen Fall. Die haben ja dann niemanden mehr.
Naja, also ehrlich gesagt, das habe ich auch jahrelang gesagt. Und dann kam Friedrich. Friedrich und Sigmar Gabriel, da hieß es ja auch, die SPD hat keinen mehr, wenn Münthe geht und da kommen dann immer noch irgendwelche Horrorgestalten aus irgendwelchen Nischen. Das glaube ich nicht, dass es ein Problem ist, weil die sind ja auch alle austauschbar. Aber bei mir hat es zu so einer Inversion geführt, die ich ganz interessant finde, dass ich rückblinkend sage, die Leute, die dann tatsächlich doch zurücktreten, die hatten noch so ein Funken von Anstand in sich. Dass sie gesagt haben, wenn wir erwischt werden und wenn die Bevölkerung meint, wir haben hier Scheiße gebaut, dann muss man auch zurücktreten. Und das habe ich also immer für selbstverständlich gehalten, wenn irgendwie so ein Skandal kommt, dann trittst du natürlich zurück. Aber das ist ja nicht mehr so inzwischen. Die überleben ja alle ein Ding nach dem anderen und gehen dann zu bilfiger Berge und machen da irgendwie Korruptionsoptimierung. Also dieser Anstand einfach auch zurückzutreten, wenn man erwischt wird oder überhaupt die Verantwortung für irgendwas zu übernehmen, das gibt es ja seit Jahrzehnten nicht mehr in Deutschland.
Aussitzen ist auch viel einfacher, wenn der Nachrichtentempo so hoch liegt. Wenn du siehst, was jetzt in der Welt alles los ist, da kommen wir noch drauf.
Du klingst wie so ein Zeuge Jehovas gerade.
Ja, aber wenn du guckst, was jetzt alles los ist, dann ist es auch viel einfacher, auszusitzen, weil in zwei Tagen sind die Nachrichten wieder anders. Dieses ganze Sommerloch, wo nichts passierte, das ist alles eigentlich nicht mehr so in der Ausmaß da.
Na, war das nicht immer so? Wir haben es nur ignoriert?
Also es gab schon noch mal eine richtige Sauerkurkenszeit.
Aber da hat sich einfach niemand für den US-Wahlkampf interessiert, dass wir heute schon zwei Jahre vor der Wahl anfangen.
Also Klimaerfolgen im nordlichen Teil der Welt sind ja im Sommer. Nur das heißt schon, dass wir im Sommer plötzlich echt viel mehr Nachrichten haben als vor zehn Jahren.
So Waldbrand und so meinst du.
Ja, nur das.
Waldbrand, Dürre und so.
Gut, das stimmt natürlich.
Nee, diese Sauerkurkenszeit gibt es eigentlich de facto auch nicht mehr. Also das ist halt eigentlich vorbei.
Na, es gibt sie noch in der Wochenverteilung, dass du sagst, innerhalb der Woche, wenn du schlechte Nachrichten hast, die machst du dann irgendwie Freitagabend. Das gibt es noch so ein bisschen.
Aber selbst hilft das nicht mehr, weil meine Spiegel online fährt halt irgendwie teilweise Storys absichtlich am Wochenende, weil niemand anderes da was tut.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite glaube ich, dass diese Landesverratsnummer deswegen so geplatzt ist, weil die versehentlich am Donnerstag schon zugestellt wurde. Weil die Post einfach schneller war, als sie geplant haben. Denn wenn das am Freitagabend gewesen wäre, wäre das genauso irgendwie unterferner liefen.
Na gut, hätten sie es bis Montag liegen lassen.
Naja, also das haben einige Male nicht funktioniert. Also am Freitag ist schon relativ geschicktes. Weil am Wochenende passieren noch andere Sachen, die du dann auch alle am Montag berichten musst. Und überhaupt am Anfang der Woche sind die Leute alle mit ihren Gedanken noch mal woanders. Das gibt es schon noch, es ist nicht mehr so ausgeprägt wie früher. Aber auf der anderen Seite führt es ja auch zu einer Abstümpfung, sodass jede einzelne Meldung nicht mehr so viel Gewicht hat wie früher. Früher gab es irgendwie fünf Meldungen am Tag, abends in der Tagesschau und die waren dann wichtig. Und den Rest hat man einfach nicht wahrgenommen. Und heute ist das so, du hast irgendwie pro Tag 100 Meldungen. Und ich sortiere mir dann da irgendwie ein paar raus. Aber da scrollen ja noch viel mehr an mir vorbei immer.
Also eines dieser Dinge, die da genau in diesen Sumpf gefallen sind, ist ja die Ukraine. Man hört da irgendwie nur noch so ganz am Rande von so. Vor ein paar Wochen war es halt so absolutes Dauerfeuer. Mit irgendwie jedem Granatwerferangriff, der da irgendwo stattfand, irgendwie hat es irgendwie gleich auf die Frontseiten der Portale geschafft.
Das ist aber menschliches Versagen, glaube ich, dass die beide Seiten versucht haben, da irgendwelche Suchmaschinenoptimierungen und irgendwie PR-Maximierungsstrategien zu fahren.
In der normalen Nachrichten?
Ja, natürlich. Aber der Punkt ist doch, dass die dann angefangen haben, einfach Non-Stories zu bringen und den Druck aufrechtzuerhalten. Und plötzlich war klar, du kannst beiden Seiten einfach auch nicht mehr trauen, wenn die irgendwie sagen, wir haben hier einen, was weiß ich, Bug gesehen irgendwo. Und zwei Tage später heißt es dann, wann der Vater Morgana, stimmt so gar nicht. Also die Hälfte der Stories, die in diesen Dauer vorher kamen, haben sich ja dann als Ende herausgestellt später. Und ich glaube, das ist einer der Gründe, warum da heute einfach keiner mehr Bock auf Ukraine-Meldungen hat, weil du einfach beiden Seiten nicht trauen kannst.
Ich glaube, es liegt doch einfach daran, dass die ganze Sache halt aussieht wie eine komplett verfahrene Situation, die halt so alle Anzeichen von diesem ewigen, keine Ahnung, Gaza-Konflikt oder sowas hat. So eine Instabilität, die jetzt da halt ist, aber die sich nicht auflösen lässt und...
Na, das ist ja auch das Ziel der Russen gewesen, oder? Binde ich jetzt schön NATO-Kräfte?
Das war strategisch für die Russen zumindest noch so eines der halbwegs optimalen Outcomes, nachdem sie halt schon nicht ihr Maximalziele erreicht haben. Also interessant dabei fand ich ja jetzt gerade die wirtschaftlichen Outcomes für die Ukraine, die ja auch völlig überschuldet ist und deren Wirtschaft komplett am Eimer ist, weil da natürlich in den umkämpften Regionen große Teile der Industrie waren, die halt viel Umsatz gemacht haben und natürlich Russland ein großer Handelspartner war und was jetzt nicht mehr so ist. Und deswegen sind die halt sowohl überschuldet als auch haben eine kaputte Wirtschaft. Aber was sie jetzt natürlich neulich bekommen haben, war das, was Griechenland seit Jahren gefordert hat, einen Schuldenschnitt.
Also Griechenland hat natürlich auch einen Schuldenschnitt bekommen, vor einer Weile schon.
Na nicht in den Dimensionen, ich meine, das war jetzt irgendwie 25 Prozent oder sowas.
Ja, aber das liegt daran, dass die Ukraine einfach einen frischen Start hatte in den 90ern. Und uns dann bei weitem nicht...
Woran das jetzt gerade liegt, ist, dass es eine politische Entscheidung.
Ja auch, aber die Ukraine hat einfach insgesamt nicht so viel Schulden gehabt wie Griechenland. Also die Wirtschaft ist viel kleiner, das heißt der Prozentwert sagt nicht so viel aus. Der absolute Wert der Schulden von Griechenland ist viel höher als der in der Ukraine. Das heißt, wenn die Ukraine jetzt mal 20 Milliarden oder so waren es ungefähr, die der Schuldenschnitt gekriegt haben. In Griechenland wäre das nicht mal in den Zeitraum gelandet. Doch. Also Griechenland hat einen Schuldenschnitt, ich glaube so 100 Milliarden oder so gekriegt vom Weltwirt.
Das haben sie gefordert, aber das haben sie nicht bekommen. Der IWF hat die ganze Zeit einen Schuldenschnitt gefordert und Deutschland hat gesagt, die ist nicht.
Das war der, den sie gekriegt haben. Sie wollen natürlich noch mehr Schulden. Also das Problem ist ja, wenn du vom IWF einen Schuldenschnitt machst, dann geben sie dir danach neue Kredite und mit denen musst du dann die Schulden......dass du hast Schulden bedienen. Ja, aber das heißt eben auch, dass du gleich wieder mehr Schulden hast. Also es ist kein wirklicher Schuldenschnitt, weil du einfach, du kommst gleich irgendwie noch mehr um drauf. Insofern ist das eher irgendwie eine Frage, wie man das jetzt berechnen will. Aber von der Größenordnung ist nicht so, dass Griechenland gar keinen Schuldenschnitt kriegt oder auch keinen substanziellen. Aber das war jetzt schon ein lustiges Timing, weil alle im Grunde drin haben, dass Griechenland jetzt einen Schuldenschnitt kriegt. Und dann kam diese Meldung so aus dem Unterholz, es gibt einen Schuldenschnitt oder so Ukraine. Gut, aber die Ukraine hat auch wirklich verloren. Muss man sagen, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie die kommissarische Regierung der Ukraine werden, dann würden wir auch lieber einen Jobwechsel machen, als da regieren wollen, oder?
Na vor allen Dingen, wenn du dir anguckst, wie die sich da jetzt als Figuren in die Regierung holen. Da war doch irgendwie hier der Schlipsfresser, wie hieß er? Sakaschvili, der tauchte da plötzlich wieder auf als Gouverneur von Odessa oder so was. Da dachte ich auch so, wie?
Der Sohn von Biden ist da doch Gas Kommissar? Oder Hunter Biden?
Ja, aber ich mein, die haben überhaupt keinen Hebel in irgendwelchem Verhandlungen. Die konnten einfach nie Nein sagen. Ja, also was...
Bloß wie verzweifelt musste sein, bevor du dir Sakaschvili als...
Eintrittst....
wie geatet. Also ich meine, wer hat dann irgendwie schlimmer versagt gegen die Russen als der? Und denen trittst du dir dann als Gouverneur ein? Das ist irgendwie... Wie kann man auf diese Idee kommen? Also das ist halt so... Irgendwie so auf dem Bizarrometer...
Es hat was sehr Multi-Python-Mäßiges.
Ja, auf diesem Bizarrometer-Auschlag-Skala war das schon irgendwie einigermaßen weit oben. Naja. Aber spannend ist ja auch genau diese ganze Wirtschafts- und Energiepolitik, die da dranhängt. Wie war das mit dem Hunter Biden? Die Geschichte war doch, dass die da auch fracken wollten, oder wie war das?
Ja, na also es gibt mehrere Fracking-Zonen in der Ukraine. Einige der größeren sind ausgerechnet in dem Rebellengebiet, aber es gibt auch noch welche an der Westgrenze. Wohl bei den Ostgebieten hatte die Firma investiert, wo Hunter Biden jetzt eigentlich dabei ist. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie realistisch das ist, dass die da überhaupt irgendwas fracken werden. Aber ich denke mal, die russischen Rebellen stehen auch mit dem Rücken an der Wand und werden da irgendwann irgendwelche wirtschaftlichen Deals machen müssen. Meinst du nicht?
Na keine Ahnung, wie wichtig den Russen nicht ist, diese offene Wunde da aufrechtzuerhalten.
Naja, das ist ja eine Sache, da die Wunde aufrechtzuerhalten und die andere Seite ist, die Leute da durchzufüttern. Ich meine, da hängen ja Existenzen von ab.
Ja, aber was sie ja beide Seiten jüngst diskutierten, war ja wieder einen Grenzzaun zu bauen. Das ist ja gerade so der...
Das ist ja der neue Trend. Das ist der neue Trend.
Ich hab da neulich mal geguckt. Tatsächlich haben alle großen Rüstungskonzerne, sowohl Boeing als auch Lockheed Martin, als auch Airbus, also die RDS und so, die haben durch die Bank alle angefangen, so vor vier, fünf Jahren, Border Defense Divisions aufzumachen. Also so Grenzzaunbauabteilungen.
Das war doch bestimmt für die Ausschreibung von der Grenze zwischen Texas und Mexiko, meinst du nicht?
Nein, nicht nur. Also tatsächlich überall Grenzen.
Ja, aber das war doch die große Monster-Ausschreibung, die am Ende überraschende Bullen gewonnen hat oder nicht?
Es gibt international so viele jetzt, die so groß sind. Zwischen Indien und Bangladesch wird es demnächst auch so vier Meter mit Elektrozaun und so geben, weil sonst die ganze Bevölkerung von Bangladesch, wenn es da mal richtig überschwemmt mit Klimawandel, in Indien reinwandelt. Überall wird es jetzt Zauner und Elektro-Fences und Invisible-Fences und Kamera-Fences und Selbstschussanlagen und Drones und das wird weltweit ein Trend sein, die nicht zu stoppen ist. Das wird Zehntausende, Hunderttausende von Kilometer an immer besser überwachte Grenzen geben, überall wo Menschen Massen drüber wollen.
Und die haben das vor fünf Jahren schon angefangen, tatsächlich zu investieren. Also die haben noch krasse Technologien, also Grenzzaun-Schnellaufbausysteme und so. Fahren sie halt mal zu einem Lkw-Train da lang und bauen halt da.
Und hinten fällt der Zaun runter.
Hinten wird der Zaun in den Boden richtig so und so.
Meine Güte, folgen die dem Trend oder haben die den Trend gemacht und reden der Politik ein?
Nee, die folgen dem Trend.
Die folgen, glaube ich, doch dem Trend.
Ich weiß noch, dass wir in 2005 schon darüber geredet haben, dass diese Flüchtlingsströme kommen werden und auch, dass es größere und größere Interessen gibt, die zu stoppen. Nicht nur an der Mexiko-US-Grenze, sondern überall. Aber guck dir an, Ungarn baut jetzt große, das war noch voriges Wochenende, Griechenland, Macedonien, Ungarn. Überall wollen die Leute jetzt Stacheldreizeune, Kameradschaft.
Schafft auch mal jetzt Plätze.
Ja, liebst so wenig möglich. Am besten alles automatisiert.
Selbstanstellen, wo man gar nicht so richtig dran denkt. Zum Beispiel die Saudis bauen sowas auch gerade an der Grenze zum Irak und an der Grenze zu Jägen an einigen Stellen. Das heißt also, die versuchen da an schwer zugänglichen Grenzstellen halt möglichst viel mit Zaun zu lösen. Und die Vorredner waren halt die Israelis.
In der Türkei ist davon auch die Rede.
Na ja, eigentlich waren wir die Vorredner.
Na gut, gut, die DDR waren diejenigen, die es ganz am Anfang mal ausprobiert haben.
Guck dir mal, was für Exportchancen da verloren gegangen sind.
Ja, kam leider ein bisschen zu spät für diese Generation, ne?
Nee, das war hervorragend. Das hat uns in Ikea die Möbel billig gemacht. Das ist keineswegs wirtschaftlich ein Problem gewesen für Westdeutschland, im Gegenteil. Das hat uns hier die Wirtschaft gerettet.
Ja, nee, aber die ganze Industrie, ihr hattet die ganze ostdeutsche Industrie, die diese Zaun gemacht hat.
Ach so, ja, die haben geschlafen. Das sind halt keine Kapitalisten gewesen, die konnten das nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich haben ein paar von den damals Verantwortlichen irgendwie noch Consulting-Posten angenommen, rechtzeitig bevor sie in Rente mussten oder so. Wäre durchaus denkbar. Die Frage ist ja natürlich, wie geht es weiter? Also werden wir sowas auch innerhalb von Europa sehen?
Sehen wir doch, Ungaben baut das jetzt gerade.
Ja, sogar innerhalb von EU-Europa. Soll ich mal so... Schengen, ja. Werden wir eine Festung Schengen mit Außenbefestigungen sehen oder wird es eher... also ich hatte so zwischendurch die Furcht, als ich im Sommer rumgefahren bin, da hab ich so ein bisschen geguckt, an welchen, in meinen Grenzübergangsstellen sie wirklich die ganze Örne weggeräumt haben und wo es noch steht. Und es steht eigentlich überall, wo es mal einen Grenzkontrollpunkt gab, steht eigentlich noch alles. Also stehen die ganzen Häuser und die Spuren und so und wo sie die Häuser weggerissen haben, quasi in ganz Richtung Osteuropa, wo ich unterwegs war. Und da, wo sie halt weggerissen haben, sind zumindest Containerfundamente, sodass man schnell Containerbüros da hinstellen kann und Sperren hinmachen kann und so. Die einzigen, wo nix war, waren halt so die alten Grenzübergänge nach Polen, die halt vor Schengenzeiten einfach geschlossen waren. Also wo halt einfach man sowieso nicht rüber kam. Also zumindest scheint keiner der Staaten da in der Gegend irgendwie so richtig dauerhaft an unkontrollierten Personenverkehr zu glauben, dass man einfach die Grenzübergänge weggebuldet hat.
Na, wenn du jetzt der, sagen wir, der Innenminister von zentral EU wärst, definiere ich jetzt mal als die Geberländer für Griechenland, siehst du irgendeinen Nachteil davon, Grenzen zu bauen? Ich meine, es ist doch Wirtschaftsförderung, es ist doch perfekt. Das ist genau, was wir jetzt brauchen.
Nee, also es remst halt die Wirtschaft schon erheblich aus.
Du musst sie ja nicht in Betrieb nehmen, aber die jetzt zu bauen und dann so als Warnung in der Hinterhand zu haben. Politisch gibt ihr das einen Hebel? Also wenn ihr nicht spurt, machen wir hier zu.
Du meinst also einfach Grenzzäune zu bauen, aber die Grenzübergänge offen zu lassen?
Ja, also jetzt noch und dann immer wenn irgendwie Terrorwarnung ist, kann man die mal einen Tag zumachen aus Populismusgründen. Also ich sehe nicht, dass es da irgendwelche Nachteile für die Politik gäbe. Das ist ja eh nicht deren Geld, was da ausgegeben wird.
Symbolisch ist aber schon verheerend. Weil ich meine Schengen ist halt schon extrem populär. Das ist halt schon so einer der wenigen Dinge, wo irgendwie so universell die Leute in der EU sagen, das ist eigentlich geil an der EU. Das funktioniert halt schon.
Stimmt natürlich.
Das ist halt auch das einzige, was man wirklich handfassen kann aus einem Euro.
Naja, auf der anderen Seite ist es aber auch die Angst vor irgendwelchen wilden EU-Eingwanderungen, ist das Nummer eins Argument der Rechtsaußenparteien, die man ja damit wegschießen könnte, wenn man einfach sagt, okay, wir haben ja aber Grenzen gebaut. Die werden dann zumachen können, wenn das ein Problem wird.
Die werden natürlich fordern, dass sie zugemacht werden. Weil die sagen, ja, das ist ja jetzt schon ein Problem. Also als politisches Symbol ist das schon ziemlich krass. Ich glaube auch, dass es vermutlich dazu kommen wird, dass wir Schengen in der Form, die wir jetzt haben, früher oder später verlieren werden. Weil eben der Druck gerade von diesen Rechtsaußenparteien und der entsprechenden Demografie zu groß wird und dann der Kontrollwahn, der dahinter steht, kommt. Aber ich vermute mal, dass sie es versuchen werden, bequem zu machen. Ob dort es auch eine Theorie dazu gibt, wie sie es vermutlich realisieren werden.
Die werden wissen wollen, wer wo ist. Das wollen die jetzt schon. Und ich glaube, die werden das einfach über die Telefone machen. Wir werden statt Personalausweise und Reisepässe werden zweiten SIM bekommen oder sowas. Und wir werden unsere Identifikation mit uns tragen. Und das macht am meisten Sinn in einem Gerät, wo schon GPS und Sender und am besten auch Mikrofon vorhanden sind.
Das Grundprinzip des nutzerfreundlichen Überwachungsstatus ist ja, nur die zu belästigen, die auch wirklich belästigt werden müssen und...
Sprich alle, wo du nicht weißt, wer sie sind. Jeder, der auf der Straße kommt und nicht identifizierbar ist, biometrisch oder durch ein Gerät.
Aber das ist ja auch scheiße, weil dann fällt ja der Aspekt weg, dass die Polizei dich belästigt und dir zeigt, dass du ein Problem bist, indem sie dich um deine Papiere bitten.
Das tun sie halt dann aber gelegentlich.
Nee, aber das kannst du ja dann einfach machen, ohne den auch nur anzusprechen, indem du einfach dein Handy ansprichst.
Ja, das passiert in Holland schon. Das heißt Gegenwirken.
Welcher Aspekt funktioniert schon?
Dass die einfach alle Orten, alle Kennzeichen mit Automatic Number plate recognition gucken und dann einfach die belästigen, die auf der Liste stehen für, die müssen mal unbequem werden hier. Da gibt es quasi Strafe über Polizei dadurch, dass du 20 mal kontrolliert wirst.
Das ist aber gezielt. Und ich meine jetzt sowas wie du willst eine Situation auflösen, sagen wir mal irgendwie lauter Hooligans vom Fußballstadion und fängst dann an, einfach die Leute einzeln zu belästigen und geben sie mal ihre Papiere her.
Also das steht ja weiterhin auf.
Das kannst du weiterhin machen.
Wenn sie schenken, auflösen wollen. Das heißt, um diese Flüchtlingssituation in den Griff zu bekommen, um der Bevölkerung sagen zu können, wir machen Festung Europa, aber es wird halt nicht lästig für euch. Wäre halt so ein Universal-ID-Ding zu sagen, du bist halt mindestens, wenn du eine Grenze überquerst, oder noch die 30 Kilometer dahinter oder so. Das sind halt die entsprechenden Reader, die halt gucken, ob dein License-Plate mit den Wireless-ID-Tags in deinem Auto übereinstimmt und Fast-Recognition, die guckt, ob du zu deinem Telefon passt. Also jetzt nicht gegen große Database, sondern einfach nur gegen den Datensatz, der damit assoziiert ist. Das funktioniert ja auch. Dann ist der Effekt halt, dass du das eigentlich nicht merkst. Weißt du, für dich ist es halt, wenn du dein Telefon dabei hast.
Aber willst du doch, dass die Leute das merken? Nein, das ist doch gerade der Pornoptikomeffekt. Du willst doch, dass die Leute wissen?
Nein, du hast es immer noch nicht verstanden. Das grundlegende Feature des modernen Überwachungsstaates ist es, die Leute nicht zu belästigen. Sie nicht merken zu lassen, dass sie überwacht werden. Die meisten Leute nicht zu belästigen. Du willst nur die Leute belästigen, die du wirklich belästigen musst, damit dein Staat weiter funktioniert.
Aber du willst doch, dass die ihr Verhalten dem anpassen, dass die überhaupt nicht überwachen.
Also, worum es sehr primär geht, ist, dass du möglichst wenig Widerstand erzeugst. Und du erzeugst möglichst wenig Widerstand, dadurch, dass die Leute einfach merken, die nicht. So wie du halt einfach an der Grenzkontrolle im Flughafen, was du eigentlich willst, ist einfach durchlaufen. Also, du willst möglichst wenig davon irgendwie belästigt werden. Und trotzdem will der Staat natürlich, dass du kontrolliert wirst, dass dein Reisepass da ist und so. Weil, guck dir diese automatischen Grenzkontrollterminals an, die sind genau dafür da. Da guckt dich niemand an, da belästigt dich niemand, da fummelt niemand in deinem Koffer rum, du hörst einfach dein Ding davon aus, blieb, läufst durch.
Du wirst einfach was die Chinesen machen. Du wirst einen Byte 8-Bit-Wert für Obedience gehorsam. Und diese 8-Bit-Wert generierst du aus alles, was öffentlich da ist, Social Media, was auch immer. Alles, was du in eigenen Datenbanken hast und alles, was du aus Segen holst. Daraus generierst du diesen 8-Bit-Wert für die ganze Bevölkerung. Und dieser 8-Bit-Wert bestimmt einfach, wie sehr du belästigt wirst. Und das heißt, alle, die belästigt werden, haben es irgendwie was getan.
They had it coming.
Eigentlich wollten wir doch eine positive Sendung machen, oder?
Dann laden wir uns Rop ein dafür, meinst du.
Scheiße.
Die Chinesen haben sowas schon vor. Und die wollen damit auch alles, was Scarcity hat. Zum Beispiel, ob jetzt für dein Kind Platz ist in der Schwimmschule, wird auch davon bestimmt, ob du als obedient gesehen wirst. Das heißt, alle, die klagen, dass kein Platz ist, die sind wahrscheinlich nicht obedient genug gewesen. Das bringt an allerhand Mechanismen, die von alleine...
Das haben wir das auch schon. Wir merken es nur nicht.
Genau, das haben wir auch schon mal prognostiziert. Wann war es? 2006, 2006 oder 2007? Wie würde man feststellen überhaupt, ob es so ein System schon gibt? Das könnte man nicht. Das ist die ideale Verschwörung. Aber darauf wird es hinauslaufen. Das wollen die. Auch wenn sie es jetzt noch nicht wissen, das wird das sein, was sie wollen. Das ist die ideal Tool of Control.
Was mich ja immer fasziniert ist, dass die ja selber nicht davon ausgehen können, dass sie ihr Leben lang Immunität haben, weil sie gerade Abgeordneter sind. Das heißt, die schaufeln sich doch ihr eigenes Grab. Das betrifft sie ja auch persönlich, was sie da bauen an Repressionssystemen. Die sehen es überhaupt nicht so, als dass sie jeweils auf dem Receiving-Seite sind.
Die kognitive Dissonanz, die haben wir doch schon häufiger gesehen. Wenn ich immer mit Leuten aus dem Innenministerium rede oder Leuten, die eine Verantwortung haben in dieser Überwachungsstaatnummer, dann ist ganz häufig bei denen zu hören, als Privatmensch finde ich das ja auch schon ganz schön gefährlich. Es geht echt ganz schön weit und irgendwie ist zu viel.
Aber ich mache hier meinen Job, oder was?
Aber irgendjemand muss es ja machen und so. Die Dynamik ist halt so. Wenn wir es jetzt nicht machen, dann wird nach dem Anschlag alles noch viel schlimmer. Das sind halt so eine Rechtfertigungsmechanismen, dass die schon einigermaßen gut verstehen, dass das, was da passiert, zu viel ist und in die falsche Richtung geht.
Aber bis auf den Verfassungsschutz ist mein Eindruck. Die haben immer noch, vielleicht ist das ja auch alles nur Schauspiel, aber wenn der Maaßen irgendwie rechtfertigen muss, was er da tut, dann packt er immer noch den gerechten Zorn aus gegen die Terroristen und wir müssen hier das Land schützen. Das klingt für mich tatsächlich aus.
Das ist aber seine Schauspielnummer, glaube ich. Manche glauben das auch selber nicht.
Also diese Dienste ist so eine ganz eigene...
Ich meine, vielleicht ist es dann auch so ein News-Bias. Wenn du halt irgendwie den ganzen Tag die Meldung darüber kriegst, welche schlimmen Terroristen sich jetzt wieder auf den Weg nach Deutschland gemacht haben, dann glaubst du natürlich irgendwann, dass das ein Problem wird. Und wahrscheinlich gibt es auch genug Spinner da draußen, um die sich kümmern müssen, dass sie glauben, dass die Welt so ist. Aber worum es halt geht, ist ja der Aufrechter halt das Status Quo, also das System irgendwie weiter zu perpetuieren. Und dazu passt halt so ein...
Die Machtstrukturen, gar nicht das System, würde ich einfach sagen.
Ja, und dazu passt halt...
Das System ist denen ja wurscht. Solange die an der Macht bleiben, würden die auch Kommunismus betreiben. Ist meine Ahnung.
Individuell vielleicht schon, als Kollektiv vielleicht nicht.
Also würden die den Unterschied überhaupt merken? Ich meine, die kriegen von oben ihre Order, von nach unten treten sie. Ja, schon.
Ich meine, so Kommunismus darf man halt wenden.
Man würde es nicht so nennen, natürlich, ja.
Aber naja, gut, ich meine, das wäre eigentlich eine gute Nachricht.
Kripernitig optimierte Wirtschaftswirtschaft.
Das wäre eigentlich eine gute Nachricht. Weil die Frage, was kommt denn jetzt eigentlich, ist ja durchaus eine große. Sollen wir jetzt mal so auf die Gesamtheit des Finanzsystems gucken. Die Krise, die wir gerade haben, ist ja eine sehr interessante. Also mit dem Börsenkreischen in China, weil die ja in einem Kontext steht, der eigentlich bedeutet, die wissen auch nicht mehr weiter. Also die haben ja alles probiert. Die Chinesen haben ja riesige Mengen Geld in den Markt gepumpt. Circuit Breaker in den westlichen Märkten, auch noch irgendwie Stützungskäufe. Es hat irgendwie am Ende jetzt nur, weil man sich kollektiv darauf geeinigt hat, dass jetzt noch nicht Crash ist. Nicht wirklich gecrashed war so mein Gefühl. Also deswegen ist halt nur jetzt so drei Tage Crash war und nicht irgendwie gleich irgendwie the big one.
Na es gibt so ein zirkuläres System, was fast ein bisschen an Ozeanströmungen erinnert, von verschiedenen Aktoren, die sich gegenseitig am Leben halten. Und was diesen China-Crash jetzt auszeichnet, ist, dass die Chinesen ihre eigene Rolle in der Aufrechterhaltung des westlichen Systems hatten, in dem sie immer schön die Kohle, die sie mit ihren Exporten reingenommen haben, im Westen reinvestiert haben. Und das fällt jetzt weg, wenn sie plötzlich anfangen, also diesen Gebörsen-Crash ging voraus, dass sie den One-Up gewertet haben kurz, und das kam auch völlig überraschend. Eigentlich war der immer absichtlich an den Dollar genagelt. Das ist als Zeichen gesehen worden, dass die Chinesen mit ihrer Wirtschaft auch gerade sehen, dass es dem Ende entgegengeht. Dieses ewige Wachstum geht halt nicht ewig lange. Und daraufhin ist halt die Börse gecrashed. Und das heißt eben, dass die zur Rettung ihrer Börse die Kohle ausgeben, die sie sonst in den Westen gepumpt haben. Und deswegen zerfällt jetzt auch der Rest vom System so ein bisschen. Und alle machen sich Sorgen. Das ist also kein chinesisches Problem, will ich gerade sagen, sondern das ist ein Problem von uns allen, dass einfach jetzt ein Teil der Ozeanströmung wegfällt. Und das muss jetzt irgendwo anders herkommen, die Kohle, die Wall Street am Leben hält. Das muss jetzt irgendwie ein Arco-Dollar sein. Was meinst du mit Entkopplung?
Die Chinesen haben jetzt angefangen, große US-Staatsanleihen zu verkaufen.
Die sie immer gekauft haben vorher, das waren genau die Stütze des westlichen Systems.
Sowohl selber als über Belgien, wo komischerweise große Teile der US-Staatsanleihen würden über irgendwelche Zwischenfirmen in Belgien betrieben. Also Belgien plötzlich einer der größten Halter von US-Staatsanleihen. Das geht jetzt alles.
Aber nur, wenn du die Länder betrachtest und den Fett nicht mitzählst, denn der Fett ist nämlich der größte.
Mittlerweile verkaufen die groß, größer als je. Und das gibt also eine Entkopplung, diese Verbindung zwischen US und chinesischer Wirtschaft, die immer als Grund dafür gegeben wurde, dass es da könnte es nie Konflikte geben, weil die sind zu sehr verknüpft. Das wird also im Moment weniger.
Die interessante Entwicklung dabei ist ja das Parallel dazu, ja auch der Petrodollar, also genau dieser Mechanismus, den sie mit Saudi-Arabien hatten.
Das ist ja ein anderer Mechanismus, der die Westwirtschaft gestärkt ist.
Also die andere Ozeanströmung. Dass der jetzt ja durch den Ölpreis zerbröselt, was vielleicht eine offensichtlich ungewollte Konsequenz der Politik der niedrigen Ölpreise ist. Die Saudis ja gerade fahren und die...
Na fahren denn wirklich die Saudis das?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich eine saudische Politik.
Die haben doch nur zu verlieren dabei, oder?
Naja, eben vielleicht auch nicht. Also die Kalkulation der Saudis...
Die Russen zu ärgern war irgendwie die neueste Theorie, ne?
Nein, die Kalkulation der Saudis ist halt zum einen, wollen sie halt die Frecking-Buden in den USA loswerden, indem sie halt Öl billiger machen, als die produzieren können. Was ihnen offenbar im ersten Anlauf erstmal nicht gelungen zu sein scheint.
Na, weil die subventioniert werden, dann kannst du ja nicht subventionieren.
Das auch, aber zum anderen haben die einfach aufgehört, neue Löcher zu bohren, gesagt, okay, die zwei, drei Jahre, bis die Saudis sich wieder beruhigt haben, können wir halt irgendwie aus den Löchern pumpen, die wir noch haben. Und zwar dann halt zu relativ niedrigen Kosten und dann wird es erst wieder teuer, wenn man halt anfängt, neue Löcher zu bohren. Und zum anderen geht es natürlich um Russland. Und die interessante Theorie ist halt, dass die Saudis, die Russen dazu zwingen wollen, Unterstützung für Assad einzustellen, also um halt Syrien sozusagen übernehmen zu können. Und dass sie deswegen halt die Russen mit dem Ölpreis halt massiv quetschen. Aber die Folgen davon sind natürlich irgendwie sehr vielfältig. Also zum einen führt es natürlich dazu, dass die Russen jetzt sich halt irgendwie Mittel und Wege suchen, wie sie halt irgendwo anders Geld verdienen können. Und dazu gehört unter anderem halt eben, direkt an die Chinesen zu verkaufen, ohne Umweg über den US-Dollar.
Was der Iran ja auch schon seit einer Weile macht.
Genau, was der Iran auch schon seit einer Weile macht. Der Iran sagt halt, naja, also wenn jetzt die Sanktionen weg sind, dann ist uns eigentlich egal, was das Öl kostet. Wir werden halt einfach eine Million Börö pro Tag schippen, was wiederum dazu führt, dass der Ölpreis halt noch weiter runtergeht.
Also eigentlich ist es ja schlecht für die Amis, wenn der Geldstrom versiegt, mit dem sie ihre Staatsanleihen absetzen konnten, weil das eben heißt, dass sie mehr Zinsen zahlen müssen, um Schulden zu machen. Auf der anderen Seite müssen sie aber auch weniger Schulden machen, wenn das Öl nicht so teuer ist. Das kompensiert sich so ein bisschen gegenseitig, weil das sehr gut für die US-Wirtschaft ist und dann kommen mehr Steuern rein. Aber das geht nicht langfristig so weit. Die Frage ist, was jetzt zuerst auffährt, ob jetzt die Chinesen sich wieder fangen oder ob der Ölpreis sich wieder verhängt. Denn die Saudis machen ja Verlust, die haben halt eine riesige Kriegskasse, aber eigentlich machen die Verlust gerade mit dem Ölpreis oder nicht?
Sie machen nicht Verlust, aber ihr Haushalt ist nicht ausgeglichen.
Naja, das ist ja Verlust machen oder nicht?
Naja, Verlust machen heißt, dass sie das Öl teurer fördern, als sie verkaufen. Das machen sie nicht, das ist schwierig bei 10 Dollar Förderungskosten. Aber die Haushalte aller Öl von einander sind de facto nicht ausgeglichen, die halt darauf angewiesen sind.
Außer Norwegen, glaube ich.
Außer Norwegen, ja. Weil die halt relativ wenig von den Öleinnahmen direkt in den Haushalt pumpen, sondern geht ja in diesen Sovereign Birth Fund, also diesen Investmentfond, den sie für Zukunft gebaut haben. Und die große Frage ist halt, zu welchen politischen Verhörungen noch führt. Also ich meine, die syrische Konfliktzone, da ist ja quasi die, die uns am nächsten angeht, weil die Flüchtlinge daherkommen. Und die werden nun hart merken. Und was da ja aber gerade passiert ist, dass die Amis sich halt wieder grandios verzocken. Also die haben jetzt angefangen mit den Türken, zu sagen, wir wollen gerne die türkische Airbase in Çelik nutzen. Die ist halt relativ nah an dem Gebiet ran, um halt Angriffe gegen den IS zu fliegen. Und daraufhin haben die Türken gesagt, ja okay, gut.
Aber dann halten die die Fresse, wenn wir die Kurden bombardieren.
Nee, wollen wir mal mitmachen so. Und dann haben sie halt irgendwie drei Angriffe gegen den IS geflogen und 300 gegen die Kurden. Und die Amis fühlen sich jetzt gerade so ein bisschen verschaukelt, aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was sie da machen, was sie da gut tun können, weil sobald sie halt irgendwie zu laut aufbegehren, dürfen sie halt die Airbase nicht mehr benutzen.
Wobei, wenn man sich auf der Karte anguckt, welcher Teil von Syrien gerade von wem kontrolliert wird, da hat Assad überhaupt nur noch ein Drittel oder ein Viertel oder so. Und die Hälfte ist in der Hand von ISIS und der Rest sind die Kurden. Was die jetzt alle von dem Assad noch wollen, der ist irgendwie das kleinste Problem in Syrien gerade. Die ISIS kontrolliert die Küste.
Die ISIS kontrolliert vor allem Wüste.
Das Gebiet ist groß, aber das Öl ist da, wo die Kurden sind. Also die haben halt schon ein paar Ölquellen, aber jetzt nicht die wirklich großen Felder. Zumindest nicht von denen man weiß. Möglicherweise gibt es ja da noch unbekannte Gegenden, wo noch Ölquellen sind, von denen man noch nicht weiß. Die Frage, wie ein Endgame für Syrien aussehen kann, ist halt vollständig unbeantwortet. Weil Assad hat halt irgendwie alle Gründe, halt nicht aufzugeben. Die Kurden wollen natürlich auch irgendwie ihren eigenen Staat am Ende haben. Die Türken wollen es auf gar keinen Fall haben. Die irakische Regierung kriegt nichts auf die Reihe. Ich kann nicht absehen, dass dieser Konflikt da noch irgendwie in den nächsten Jahren irgendwie zu befrieden ist.
Da sind aber substanzielle Ölfelder in Syrien, auch in der Wüste, im ISIS-Gebet.
Ah, in Syrien, ja, okay. Das kann gut sein, ja.
Ja, aber das heißt, der Assad steht ja schon praktisch am Fenster. Muss nur noch hüpfen. Nur, also so richtig Kontrolle hat er ja eh nicht über das Land, will ich damit sagen. Das heißt, da jetzt irgendwie, was die alle von dem noch wollen, anstatt dass die mal irgendwie die Riesensäge wegbomben. Also die Russen halten den so gerade so über Wasser, weil sie ja diesen scheiß Hafen da brauchen.
Und den Gaspipeline nach den Qatar-Fields blockieren wollen.
Wie war die Geschichte?
Es gibt diesen Pipeline von diesen Qatari-Fields, da gibt es Offshore-Gas-Fields. Und die müssten eigentlich mit der Türkisch-Höpp verbunden werden. Sobald die da sind, ist der Macht von Putin über den EU-Gasmarkt gebrochen. Und das wollen die Russen nicht. Und deswegen blockieren die diesen Pipeline über Syrien.
Interessante Theorie von Qatar, okay. Das heißt also, der...
Ja, na wo würdest du die sonst langlegen? Durch Saudi-Arabien, die haben natürlich auch kein Interesse daran. Uh, das ist ja mal nicht unspannend.
Okay, die Frage ist natürlich, würde man da überhaupt jemals irgendein Pipeline durchlegen können? Also durch Syrien, so wie es jetzt gerade ist? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Na die Alternative ist durch Saudi-Arabien oder den Iran. Das ist ja auch beides keine Option.
Na durch Saudi-Arabien müssen sie sowieso. Oder?
Nee, sie können unter dem Wasser durch und dann den Iran nehmen. Und Syrien.
Irak und Syrien.
Nee, hier. Durch den Iran, jetzt nach Norden. Turkmenistan, gut ist das jetzt.
Nee, da müsste man dann schon durch den Irak durch.
Du kannst auch oben rum, das ist halt teurer. Aber bevor du durch den Irak eine Pipeline legst...
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe das jetzt durch diese Katharie Gehasvils, so die paar Analysen, die ich lesen habe, das ist schon der Hauptgrund für dieses ganze Konflikt überhaupt.
Weil die Katharis sind ja da irgendwie fett investiert. Also die haben ja da...
Das ist ja auch krass eigentlich. Also diese ganze Gegend irgendwie... So richtig Hoffnung habe ich da nicht.
Nee, zu viele Interessen gegenseitig, die zu viele Leute gegenseitig ausspielen. Und am Ende landen sie dann halt hier.
Nun ja, aber es gibt noch andere Sachen, die wir beobachten konnten seit der letzten Sendung, die, wie ich sie mal nennen will, die Drei-Affen-Politik von Merkel zeigt zusehends...
Nichts sehen, nichts hören, nichts sagen?
Ja, zeigt zusehends Bruchstellen.
Tut sie das?
Ja, also das ist immer mehr... Wird das in der Presse thematisiert, wieso die Merkel eigentlich da jetzt noch nichts gesagt hat?
Hört, dann sagt sie wieder, dann redet wieder keiner mehr drüber.
Ja, aber früher war das überhaupt kein Thema, sondern man hat einfach gesagt, wie toll, wie die da vor sich hin regieren. Heute ist das immerhin Thema. Ich sag nicht, die ist vorbei, aber sie zeigt die ersten Bröseleffekte, finde ich. Und die Leaker gehen langsam in die Offensive.
Lass mal kurz bei dieser Dreieraffen-Geschichte bleiben. Da sollen wir jetzt mal die Flüchtlingsproblematik angucken.
Ich meine jetzt nicht von der Flüchtlingsgeschichte, sondern diese NSA-Ausläufer und NSU, wie dann irgendwie immer nach ein paar Monaten die Frage in der Presse kommt, wann eigentlich das Kanzleramt davon wusste. Und dann kommt völlig überraschend raus, dass die seit Jahren informiert sind. Aber diese Anklage gab es früher einfach überhaupt nicht, ob das Kanzleramt über irgendwas informiert sei. Diese Frage wurde früher gar nicht gestellt, das meine ich damit. Also ob das jetzt gut oder schlecht ist, weiß ich nicht, weil sie ja nach wie vor aussitzen können und damit durchkommen. Aber so ein bisschen final der Hoffnung ist das für mich schon, dass die Presse jetzt zumindest mal anfängt nachzufragen, ob da vielleicht auch in Richtung Kanzleramt mal jemand nach personellen Konsequenzen fragen könnte. Also unwahrscheinlich das ist, dass da irgendwas passiert, aber immerhin passiert überhaupt was. Man muss sich ja an den kleinen Sachen erfreuen.
Ich weiß nicht, für mich stellt sich das eher so dar, als wenn Merkel dann halt sagt dann mal irgendwas, dann ist alle wieder zufrieden, weil sie das gesagt hat und dann passiert wieder entweder weiter nichts oder halt irgendein Scheiß.
Na aber, dass es einen Fortschritt gibt, willst du nicht in Abrede stellen, oder?
Welchen Fortschritt denn?
Na, dass wir darüber jetzt reden, ob das Kanzleramt informiert war.
Na ja, weißt du, nach 15 Jahren kann man langsam mal darüber reden, wie dieser Politikstil funktioniert ist.
Na ja, eben, eben. Aber das ist ein Fortschritt.
Ich will jetzt nicht als Fortschritt bezeichnet sein, weil es leider überfällig ist.
Ja, naja, das schließt sich ja nicht aus.
Na gut.
Dann geht Wikileaks jetzt in die Offensive und hat ein Kopfgeld ausgeschrieben für TTIP-Leaks. Ja, das fand ich auch, ich will nicht sagen, eine Zeitenwende, aber so. Also, Herr Leverer, vielen Dank an die NGOs. Ich weiß es nicht, aber dass ein NGO so offensiv in die Politik einzugreifen versucht, das haben wir glaube ich vorher noch nicht gehabt. Also höchstens vielleicht irgendwie Greenpeace, aber das ist ja nicht vergleichbar.
Ich meine, das ist ja schon so ein...
Das ist eine krasse Nummer auf jeden Fall....
ein kleiner Schritt Richtung Assessination Politics. Also zumindest so ganz grob die Richtung.
Ja, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass da einige Leute auch richtig schlecht schlafen gerade. Im Apparat, wenn irgendwie jemand ein Kopfgeld auf deine geheimen Daten aussetzt.
Ja, andererseits, meine TTIP ist so ein Problem, ist halt wieder so ein Skandal, der viel zu komplex ist.
Absichtlich, das haben wir schon mal besprochen hier.
Ja, also TTIP ist halt irgendwie absichtlich so designed, dass man eigentlich die Geschichte nicht erzählen kann und damit kann man sich halt eigentlich nur quasi gegen den Namen und das Ganze wenden ohne einzelne Aspekte. Und weil draus Differenzierung wird halt schwierig so in der Öffentlichkeit. Naja, ich meine, wie würdest du das denn so empfinden als Nummermann, du bist irgendwie Geheimdienstchef und du...
Da würde ich mir richtig Sorgen machen.
Julian fängt jetzt an zu sagen so, hey, 100.000 für dieses Dokument. Der kriegt die Kohle auch zusammen.
Guck mal, bisher ist der doch in der Defensive, sitzt in seiner Botschaft. Er hat gerade gesagt, dass er Angst vor Ermordung hat und deswegen seit Jahren das Sonnenlicht nicht mehr gesehen hat und immer nur noch per Internet mit anderen Leuten redet und er sieht inzwischen aus wie Gandalf der Weiße. Ja. Und der geht jetzt in die Offensive, da würde ich mir schon Sorgen machen. Also ich meine, er hat bisher bewiesen, dass er es erfolgreich schaffen kann, sich jahrelang den Geheimdiensten der Welt zu entziehen. Das ist ja auch schon mal eine Leistung gewesen. Aber das wirkte immer noch so, als wenn er in der Defensive ist. Und ausgehendet der erklärt jetzt die Offensive. Das finde ich schon, da kann ich mir vorstellen, dass da einige Krisenstäbe eingerichtet wurden und irgendwie Arbeitsgruppen in irgendwelchen Diensten. Weil, okay, jetzt müssen wir mal was tun, das geht so nicht. Das können die nicht dulden, oder?
Tja, na was wollen sie tun?
Na, keine Ahnung, irgendwie wirtschaftlichen Druck auf Ecuador. Was weiß ich, was man da tun kann?
Ich meine, die Schwierigkeit ist natürlich, wie setzt man sowas eigentlich um? Also wie übergibt man einem Leaker 100.000 Euro dafür?
Bitcoin.
Also ich sag mal so, wenn ich, nehmen wir mal an, ich würde... Bargeld? Nehmen wir mal an, ich würde...
Ein Bargeldkoffer aus der Ecuadorianischen Botschaft.
Ich würde die Amis in dieser Art und Weise ärgern, dass ich halt den TTIP-Vertrag leake, in der vorstündigen Version.
Und das Geld dann an Frau Merkel zahlen.
Nee, ich meine, ich weiß zumindest nicht, ob ich Bitcoin wollen würde.
Nee, aber da kannst du doch Leute mit versinken, oder? Wenn du dann 100.000 Euro zahlst. An irgendjemanden, den du schon immer weghaben wolltest. Ich sag jetzt mal Herrn Maaßen.
Stimmt, sehr preiswert.
Ja, das wäre doch auch ein crowdfunding Ziel, wo ich auch mal irgendwie teilnehmen würde.
Stimmt. Das heißt, man schiebt es einfach jemand in die Schuhe und wartet darauf, dass die Amis den Job erledigen. Aber trotzdem, meine 100.000 Euro würde ich glaube ich nicht in Bitcoin haben wollen, in so einem Fall. Dafür ist man der Ledger zu Public.
Du musst nur warten, bis es anonymes Zero Cash, Zero irgendwas ist. Musst es nur zehn Jahre stehen lassen können.
Ein Koffer mit Bargeld für 100.000 Euro ist jetzt auch nicht so groß. Das kann man noch rumtragen.
Die Frage ist, will man es rumtragen?
Nein, aber da brauchst du nicht mal einen Koffer für. Wir haben ja anständig große Euronoten. Also da würde ich mir jetzt keine Sorgen machen.
Würdest du eine Serie nochmal haben wollen?
Nein, aber wenn du die irgendwo liegen lässt, die Kohle.
Das ist zumindest schon ein interessantes Problem.
Keine Frage, aber dass überhaupt ihnen jemand offen den Krieg erklärt, was es ja ist, das finde ich schon. Da werden auf jeden Fall einige Leute sehr nervös werden.
Die Frage ist, ob da genügend Mobilisierungspotenzial drin steckt.
Sie haben nach einem Tag die Hälfte drin gehabt.
Andersrum, wenn der Vertrag sozusagen da ist, nehmen wir mal an, sie kriegen es übermorgen und liegen es.
Ob wir den dann gestoppt kriegen, meinst du?
Ob es reichen würde, TTIP zu stoppen.
Der ganze Punkt von solchen Handelsverträgen ist nicht, dass man sie ganz stoppen möchte. Man möchte das Schlimmste da rausholen. Das ist das Beste, was man als Aktivist machen kann. Die schlimmsten Sachen rausholen. Der Punkt ist, die machen alle zwei Jahre so einen neuen Zug mit neuen Verträgen, neue. Und alles, was vom einen Zug abfallt, wird einfach auf den nächsten Zug wieder raufgetan. Alles, was aus Akta schlecht war, ist wieder drin. Und du kannst nicht alle zwei Jahre für das gleiche Thema mobilisieren. Sprich irgendwann gewinnen die und die können einfach abschätzen, man würde sogar extra noch Sachen drauf tun, um abgeschossen zu werden.
Warum sind die denn so mit dieser Geheimhaltung gefahren? Die können auch ganz offensiv sagen, wir machen einfach dasselbe, wie was bei Akta schon war.
Wäre funktioniert.
Hätte funktioniert, hätte auf jeden Fall funktioniert. Diese Geheimhaltung macht das auch angreifbar. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn ich jetzt der nächste Kanzler wäre, dass ich einfach sage, dieses Verfahren, oder jetzt mal irgendwie, was weiß ich, Elfefe, dass ich sage, dieses Verfahren, dieses Verfahren, wie das zustande gekommen ist, ist schon so undemokratisch, dass dieses ganze Ding nicht gilt und wir treten jetzt aus.
Das Argument, was sie da selber für geben, um diese Geheimhaltung zu fahren, ist glaube ich teilweise auch gültig, nämlich dass man solche Sachen einfach schwer verhandeln kann, wenn alles offen ist. Man muss quasi auch sagen, Geheimheiten, damit man sie überhaupt verhandelt bekommt. Und da sehen sie sich leider uns alle gegenüber. Aber sie sehen sich aufeinander gegenüber.
Wir sind doch aber der Souverän an der Stelle. Die können nicht ohne mich verhandeln. Und dann kann ich nur noch...
Doch, können die. Leider. Also das ist halt eben die Frage, wenn du auf der anderen Seite halt jemand hast, der halt irgendwie mit fünf Leuten verhandeln kann plus deren Team und du auf der anderen Seite deine gesamte Verhandlungsposition jeden Tag öffentliche machen musst, ist schon klar, wer gewinnt. Dass die im Geheimen verhandeln wollen, kann ich schon verstehen.
Es gibt ja auch einen Hebel, wenn du sagst, ihr könnt ja sehen, dass das nicht durchkommt. Dieser Posten kommt nicht durch, fertig.
Wäre aber ein Style von Verhandlungen, den die so nicht gewohnt sind. Ja, aber wäre doch mal geil, oder?
Stell dir mal vor, jemand verhandelt zu uns, sagt, sie können sehen, dass ich mit ihrer Forderung, die ist bei mir nicht umsetzbar, fertig, ist nicht verhandelbar, weil sie können ja sehen, wie die öffentliche Meinung bei uns ist.
Deswegen machen die es geheim.
Ja, na klar.
Aber noch mal zu diesem Thema. An diese ganze Handelsabkommenstrend von der letzten paar Jahre kann man auch sehen, dass die auch gut schnallen, dass sie am Höhepunkt ihren Macht sind. Die ganze Transatlantikbrücke, die Monsantos der Welt verstehen, dass sie jetzt festnageln müssen, so fest wie es geht mit diesen internationalen Arbitrage und die müssen so fest wie möglich nageln, was sie jetzt haben, weil ab hier wirds schlimmer. Ab hier werden zumindest in ein paar Länder werden die Bevölkerung versuchen, die Macht wieder zurückzubekommen, werden versuchen zu regulieren, werden versuchen, die verstehen schon, dass sie jetzt, was sie haben, festmachen müssen.
Ich habe das so gedeutet, dass das als Zeichen dafür, dass die Macht des Militärs abnimmt, dass wir Sachen jetzt zivil regeln müssen, weil die Bevölkerung immer mehr, und auch im US-Wahlkampf ist das ja mal wieder ein Thema, ob wir tatsächlich so viel Militärausgaben brauchen in den USA. Und wenn man als Unternehmen einfach sieht, womit wir jetzt durchkommen, hängt davon ab, dass wir überall Militärbasen haben und möglicherweise haben wir die in zehn Jahren nicht mehr. So hab ich das... Es ist fast das selbe.
Bestimmt auch, aber ZITEP ist ein großes Versuch, dafür zu sorgen, dass die Bevölkerung sich selbst nicht durch politische Maßnahmen aus dieser Scheiß rauswählen können.
Also de facto ist es ja die Zementierung des globalisierten Neokolonialismus bzw. der neoliberalen Ideologie, wo sie halt versuchen, sich aus allem Einfluss, den eine Regierung haben könnte, demokratisch gewählte, möglichst rauszuziehen.
Ja, es ist der Ayn Rand-Vertrag, ne?
Diese Regulierung geht leider nicht. Wir verstehen, dass ihre Bevölkerung das will, aber sie geht leider nicht, weil wir haben uns schon irgendwelche Gewinne eingebildet.
Ja, genau.
Wir haben uns schon verpflichtet.
Ja, Ayn Rand-Vertrag trifft ziemlich genau. Das ist interessant, also wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen, die machen da jetzt gerade so viel Druck, weil sie wissen, dass es jetzt langsam Endgame ist für diese Art von Wirtschaftspolitik. Und sie wissen halt jedes Jahr, was sie noch rausschinden können, bringt ihnen richtig Geld. Also jedes Jahr, wo sie die Miss- teile des Staates Quo noch irgendwie weiter aufrechterhalten können, lohnt halt richtig.
Bis es alle wollen, können wir die, die sich versuchen aus dem Scheiß rauszuwählen, richtig nochmal strafen.
Als Outcast, ja.
Wir können die richtig Outcast machen, dafür, dass sie es gewagt haben, sich aus der Scheiß rauszuwählen. Und damit hoffen wir, die ganze Status Quo noch mal fünf Jahre länger oder zehn Jahre länger zu erhalten.
Das ganze WTO-System, was da dran hängt, das World Trade Organization, war ja der Versuch, so was im globalen Maßstab zu machen und irgendwann sind sie dann auf Granit gebissen, weil sie halt...
Nein, das hat halt überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Es gab ja dieses Antigua-Ding, was so das Fanal der Hoffnung war, dass die WTO möglicherweise funktioniert und auch mal was gegen die Amis beschließen könnte. Und es haben am Ende in einem Verfahren ist Antigua das Recht zugesagt worden, dass sie Raubkopien verkaufen dürfen von amerikanischen Produkten. Und das hat Antigua trotzdem nicht machen können, weil ihnen sonst die Wirtschaft geplatzt wäre. Das heißt, die WTO hat sich herausgestellt als zwar pseudo-global agierende Vereinigung, aber am Ende ist der Hegemonen immer noch die USA. Und gegen die kannst du halt nichts machen. Und dieses T-Tipp-Zeug geht meines Erachtens in dieselbe Richtung. Das ist eben der Versuch der USA, ihre Hegemonie auf alle zur Verfügung stehenden Arten festzuschreiben.
Das ist eine Interpretation, aber ich glaube das...
Aber wie kommt ihr denn darauf, dass das Endgame aus deren Sicht so nahe ist? Meint ihr nicht, das läuft doch seit 20 Jahren, sagen die Leute, jetzt ist hier bald Ende? Wieso soll es nicht noch 20 Jahre laufen?
Naja, wenn du schon solche Verträge machen musst, um dafür zu sorgen, dass die Leute sich nicht da raus wählen, dann...
Aber haben wir das schon? WTO ist auch eine Sache, aus der du dich nicht rauswählen kannst. Und da haben sie nach vielen Jahren... Das fand ich absolut unfassbar, dass sie es nicht nur geschafft haben, dass Russland diesem Scheiß beigetreten ist, dem Intellectual Property-VIPRO, sondern dass Russland noch der Bittsteller war, dem sie Konditionen aufdrängen konnten, dafür, dass sie reingelassen werden in das internationale System, was nur zu ihren Lasten besteht. Das war schon vor TTIP so, dass dieser Druck und die US-Hegemonie die gesamten anderen... Das wird dann immer irgendwie in Genf angesiedelt oder so, damit es international wirkt. Auch Weltbank und Weltwährungsfonds sind ja auf dem Papier global. Aber am Ende des Tages bestimmen die USA, was da gemacht wird. Wo nehmt ihr dieses Gefühl her, dass sie Angst haben und jetzt nochmal zementieren müssen?
Die T-Tap geht davon aus, wir müssen unsere Profiten sichern, wenn Staaten anfangen zu regulieren. Wir müssen vorbeugen, dass wir Gewinne verlieren dadurch, dass irgendwas reguliert wird. Dass irgendwer versucht, genmanipulierte Stempel zu machen oder dass irgendwer versucht, irgendwelche Märkte abzuschotten oder irgendwas selber zu machen. So was ist jetzt? Das heißt nicht, dass die davon ausgehen, dass das groß passieren wird. Und das heißt, dass man davon ausgeht, dass seine Macht, dass es mehr und mehr Länder gibt, die das ganze Mitspielen nicht mehr freiwillig machen. Und das ist schon eine Änderung. Das ganze T-Tap geht davon aus, die Zeiten von flächendeckender Freiwilligkeit, weil Wachstum, weil noch ausreichend Planeten da, weil wir können noch Kippengeld über alle schütten, die irgendwie mitspielen. Das ist jetzt vorbei, die Freiwilligkeit ist vorbei. Jetzt müssen wir zwingen. T-Tap ist schon eine neue Phase.
Also was ich ja nicht verstehe an T-Tap ist, dass ausgerechnet Obama das macht und nicht ein republikanischer Präsident. Denn das schneidet ja in beide Richtungen. Also es ist ja auch so, zum Beispiel, wenn Volkswagen findet, dass sie irgendwelche Hürden haben in Amerika, dass irgendeine Regulierung ihnen im Weg ist, zum Beispiel bei Kalifornien wieder irgendwelche Einzeldinger machen.
In der Kontraktung, dass es sich dabei um einen reinen US-Dominanz-Ding handelt, ist meines Erachtens falsch. Ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich eben der Versuch von den A&Rant-Lobbigen dieser Welt, ihr System weiter zu zementieren. Also dafür zu sorgen, dass halt dieser globalisierte Kapitalismus, in dem Regierungen nichts mehr zu sagen haben, in dem es also auch keine Interferenzen gibt.
Nicht voll auf deiner Seite. Allerdings, ich deute das im Moment so, dass die USA das im Moment noch durch ihre Hegemonie den anderen aufdrücken können, dass sie das machen wollen.
Aber die werden benutzt dafür.
Allerdings haben auch die USA nur Nachteile von TTIP. Weil jetzt Volkswagen sagen kann, die Asbestregulierung in Kalifornien ist zu viel. Nein, aber warum macht denn Obama das? Nicht mal die USA haben Vorteile davon.
Glaubst du, Obama hat eine Handlungsfreiheit?
Nein, aber das ist doch was ich meine. Nicht mal, der schießt sich doch zukünftige Regulierungsversuche seiner eigenen Partei weg. Was die einzige Sache ist, die die Demokraten von den Republikanern unterscheiden.
Jetzt musst du, wenn du quasi Monsanto bist, du musst jetzt Lobby dafür sein, dass du alles kriegst, was du willst. Jetzt musst du in alle Länder der Welt, die, die da zufällig an der Macht sind, entweder kaufen oder irgendwelche Vorteile geben. Überall, weltweit. Das ist doch unheimlich viel Stress, wenn du da irgendeinen Vertrag hast, dass die alle unterschrieben haben, dass die einfach nicht mehr anders können.
Ich verstehe das ja von und ganz, aber ich frage mich, wie die es schaffen, so einen Vertrag zu machen, wenn alle Signatoren Nachteile davon haben. Es muss ja irgendjemand geben, der das drückt. Und wenn du ein Lobbyist bist und du gibst mir Geld, dann kriegst du mich dazu alles Mögliche zu tun. Aber du kriegst doch nicht dazu, mir selbst zu schaden.
Wenn ich sage, ich gebe dir Geld und du schießt dir in den Fuß, das machst du doch nicht. Moment, dir selbst ist ja die USA. Du nimmst in diesem Fall an, dass Obamas Interessen identisch sind mit denen der USA.
Na ja, also das ist ja seine Zukunft von seiner Existenz an der Partei abhängt oder nicht?
Obama muss nicht mehr.
Fürs Amt, aber der wird jetzt irgendwie rumgereicht.
Na ja, der braucht halt einfach nur noch irgendwie Vorträge für eine Vierteljohnen Dollar halten, bei den Leuten, die ihn für TTIP bezahlt haben. Mehr hat er im Leben nicht mehr zu erwarten. Das ist quite simple.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Also wie gesagt, die nationalen Interessen sind da, glaube ich, halt eher zweitrangig. Also deswegen finde ich auch diese Darstellung, die in Deutschland ja leider passiert ist in der Antität der Bewegung, dass es irgendwie so Europa gegen die USA ist, ist halt eigentlich ziemlich ja Quatsch. Worum es halt geht, ist halt tatsächlich die Zementierung des Android-Kapitalismus. Und das, glaube ich, auch eine Perspektive, die es halt auch leichter macht, irgendwie dagegen zu argumentieren. Weil man sagt, okay, worum es da am Ende nicht geht, ist ob jetzt irgendwie amerikanische Klau-Hühnchenregulierung oder was auch immer. Da sind halt irgendwie ja die...
Die großen multinationalen Unternehmen haben einfach keinen Bock darauf, dass überall irgendwelche Syriza-Parteien an der Macht kommen und anfangen, Sachen zu regulieren.
Das geht auch nicht.
Ende der Durchsage.
Weil es halt eben doch absehbar ist, dass das passieren wird.
Ja.
Wann es jetzt passiert, also wann die Krise kommt, die halt dazu führen wird, dass die jetzigen politischen Systeme halt irgendwie nicht mehr weiter stabil sind, ist halt nicht absehbar. Aber klar ist halt, dass an irgendeinem Punkt wird halt dieses ganze multinationale Schuldenspiel schwierig weiter zu betreiben, so. Und da halt irgendeinen Weg zu finden, zumindest noch ein paar Jahre rauszustellen. Ich meine, letztendlich ist das, was die da tun, genau wie das, was die Mobilfunkoperatoren mit SMS machen. Die nehmen die halt immer noch irgendwie 15 Cent oder sowas pro SMS ab, so lange sie es können. So, und erst wenn wirklich der Letzte aufgehört hat, SMS zu schicken, werden sie sich dem überbrücken.
Wo sind die Schulden der Staaten? Das sind doch im Ende, sind das die private Vermögen und die private Gewinne. Und wenn ein privates Gewinn nicht abgenommen wird, weil die Bevölkerung dafür gewählt hat, dann Bergbau-Dings nicht zu verlängern, dann wirst du einfach sagen können, hey, da habe ich so eine internationale Abitrage, Dings, was Quatsch ist.
Genau, in Washington.
Und ich möchte gerne trotzdem meine 300 Millionen Dollar haben und bitte zahlen. In halb zwei Wochen. Das macht doch völlig Sinn, aber es macht nur völlig Sinn, weil du glaubst, dass es demnächst mal Bevölkerung gibt, die dafür wählen, dass dein Bergbau-Kontrakt nicht weiter. Das ist alles logisch.
Also letztendlich ist ja die Frage, wird der Narrativ des globalen Kapitalismus die nächste Krise überleben? Also wird es dazu kommen, dass die Leute denken, okay, wir können noch eine Runde, eine Runde geht es noch weiter, einmal mehr kriegen wir es noch hin.
Ich beobachte gerade, dass Kapitalismus-Kritik so was wie Gutmensch wird, so ein Pseudo-Schimpfwort, dass du sagst, ach ja, irgendwie das ist jetzt abwertend gemeint, wenn du sagst, ja, mit seiner Kapitalismus-Kritik, als wenn es nicht legitim wäre, den Kapitalismus zu kritisieren. Heute wird das zusehends benutzt im Mediendiskurs als so eine Sache abwertend. Ja, ja, der ist schon wieder mit sein.
So Treehugger-mäßig, ja?
Ja, nee, auch ein Altkommunist irgendwie so. Ja, ja, da müssen wir nicht zuhören.
Ja, aber es ist auch Kapitalismus, wie wir es jetzt haben, ist auch ein ganz besonderes Ding, weil wir reden immer von freier Markt, aber es ist nichts frei daran. Es wird nicht so viel subventioniert wie Fossil Fuels. Es wird nicht so der Hand über Kopf gehalten.
Atomstrom ist auch gut subventioniert.
Die Banken werden schon längst pleite, wenn wir sie nicht mit TAP und wie es auch alles heißt, die Hand über dem Kopf gehalten hatten. Das hat nichts mit freier Markt zu tun. Die invisible hand of the market existiert gar nicht. Also das, was in der Ideologie Kapitalismus ist, beschreibt nicht, was unser System jetzt ist. Wir brauchen da quasi auch neue Terminologie dafür, weil es hat mit Kapitalismus versus andere Systeme oder Kapitalismus im Sinne von die alten Analysen hat es auch nichts zu tun. Dies ist ein internationales System von Finanzmärkten und von quasi Finanzquatsch, was alles too big to fail.
Genau, wenn man mal die Staatsquote am Finanzmarkt sich anguckt, also wie viel ist eigentlich staatlich garantiert, wie viel ist nur noch am Leben, weil die Staaten da eingesprungen sind, dann dürfte sie wahrscheinlich genauso hoch sein wie im Rest der Wirtschaft, also wahrscheinlich eher so 30 bis 50 Prozent oder so was.
Ich glaube in Deutschland wäre die Staatsquote noch nie unter 50 Prozent, von der Gesamtwirtschaft. Also die Staatsquote ist ja was anderes als Garantien, sondern wie viel von dem tatsächlich hervorliegenden Geld.
Also Staatsquote im Sinne von, würde es nicht mehr geben, wenn der Staat nicht eingegriffen hätte?
Bei den Banken hätte ich eher so 80 Prozent gedacht. Weil sonst hätten die das ja nicht gemacht. Ich glaube, dass die einfach tatsächlich irgendwelche Berechnungen gemacht haben, was alles platzt, wenn wir jetzt die, irgendwie so Lehman Brothers mäßig, wenn wir jetzt hier mal die Commerzbank zugehen lassen. Und dann stellt sich halt raus, dass die Deutsche Bank immer ganz vorne mit dabei ist, in irgendwelche Sachen zu investieren, die gerade pleite gehen. Und dann rumheult und gerettet werden muss.
Ohne die ganzen griechischen Hilfspakete mit Quotes hätte es die Landesbanken schon nicht mehr gegeben. Eben, eben.
Ja, naja gut.
Okay, aber was wir da eigentlich, also wenn man sich diese Struktur anguckt, also diesen staatsverwobenen Kapitalismus oder wie auch immer man das nennt, dann ist aber letztens wieder die Frage, ob bei der nächsten Krise noch mal auf Kosten der Allgemeinheit gerettet wird. Stellt sich hier dann schon.
Der Punkt ist, viel Munition, was die Zentralbanken und Staaten hatten, um auf Krisen zu schießen, machen die jetzt schon volle Kanne maximal.
Und zwar im Tagesgeschäft. Nicht mehr nur in Notfällen, sondern immer. Ich würde das anders umformulieren. Ich würde sagen, was kann jetzt überhaupt noch passieren, was nicht sofort eskalieren müsste mit vollem Staatsrettungsprogramm.
Was passiert denn momentan im Standardprogramm?
Lass uns mal 30 Jahre zurückdenken auf die Kohleförderung in Westdeutschland. War das nicht auch schon immer so ein too big, too fail Ding, und wir müssen aber hier Kohle reinpumpen, weil sonst platzt alles? Ich würde sagen, das hat eine historische Vorbilder. Und wir machen das eigentlich schon immer so. Wir haben das nur noch nicht in diesem Umfang gemacht. Also das was neu ist.
Wo so wenig hinten bei raus kam, was irgendwie anfassbar war. Also wo so wenige Arbeitsplätze bei rum kamen.
Also wenn du bei den Kohle-Bergbau-Gebieten guckst, ist da Dorfer absacken und irgendwie Straßen und alles vor sich hin kammelt.
Aber da gab es halt richtig 100.000 Arbeitsplätze für.
Ja, aber das musst du auch gegenrechnen. Das sind ja auch Posten, die werden jetzt immer so getan, als würden wir auch, wir mussten halt die Straße reparieren. Aber das sind ja eigentlich Folgekosten vom Bergbau auch. Und wenn du das alles mit einrichtest, ist das schon auch richtig viel Kohle.
Ja, Unternehmen oberhalb einer bestimmten Grenze heißt einfach, dass man Unternehmer ist, solange es Gewinne gibt und dass man die Verluste kollektivisiert. Und dafür nimmt man politischen Einfluss. Und so funktioniert halt unser Kapitalismus. Das ist ein Kapitalismus, was nur zur Hälfte, nämlich die profitabile Hälfte, ist es privat. Und die unprofitable Hälfte ist kollektiv.
Der Leninismus hat dafür ein Wort, das ist der staatsmonopolistische Kapitalismus oder auch kurz Stamokap. Die Frage dabei ist natürlich, wie sieht denn ein Weg raus aus? Weil, nehmen wir mal an, die nächste Krise kommt. Ist so, wird wohl passieren, ob es jetzt sind drei Monate oder drei Jahre, das ist einigermaßen irrelevant. Die Frage ist, was ist dann der gewinne Narrativ? Und die Frage...
Warte mal, ich muss noch eine Sache... Ich glaube, man muss noch mal herausstellen, wie stark dieses Narrativ überhaupt ist. Dieses, der Staat muss es jetzt retten, denn sonst sind wir alle tot. Und ich glaube, am eindrucksvollsten kann man das im Moment in Australien sehen. Da ist dieser Ultra-Unsympath an der Macht, der da für die Minenkonzerne irgendwie versucht hat, das Great Barrier Reef von der UNESCO-Liste zu nehmen, damit man da irgendwie Minen bauen kann.
Ne, einen Hafen bauen kann für die Minenproduktion.
Ja, und der ist mit denselben Argumenten von der Minenindustrie Australiens, die da einen signifikanten Teil der Wirtschaft bestreitet, überzeugt worden. Die haben einfach einen Hebel gehabt. Die haben gesagt, China ist gerade am Runterfahren und die nehmen immer weniger ab. Und wenn du jetzt hier auch noch mit Umweltschutz-Scheiß kommst, dann ist unser Land weg. Also das ist durchaus ein mächtiger Hebel. Das ist nicht nur, dass die Politik irgendwie keinen Bock hat, da sich genauer mit zu beschäftigen, sondern das sind substanzielle Drohungen, die da im Raum stehen. Da geht es um die Existenz und ich denke, deswegen kann man auch nicht einfach... Ja, das ist tatsächlich so, dass die Folgen sind jetzt im Einzelnen vielleicht übertrieben, aber das sind tatsächlich existenzielle Sachen, die da im Raum stehen. So wird es unser Land überhaupt noch geben können, wenn wir jetzt aufhören, das und das zu tun. Also gerade in Deutschland mit diesen ewigen Wachstums-Heilsversprechungen und Exportweltmeister-Bullshit, da ist es ja genauso gelaufen, dass sie gesagt haben, wenn wir jetzt hier nicht die Löhne senken, dann sind wir weg vom Fenster. Es wird gar nicht mehr unterhalb von existenziellen Fragen argumentiert in der Wirtschaft, ist mein Eindruck, sondern es geht immer gleich, wenn du das nicht machst, bist du so gut wie tot. Stimmt. Und das finde ich eine Sache, das heißt, dass wir auch gar keine vernünftigen Diskursen mehr haben können, weil da kannst du kein Argument gegenbringen. Das sind alles nur noch so Totschlagargumente im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, weil es einfach heißt, wenn wir das jetzt nicht tun, sind wir tot. Und wenn du das in Verbindung setzt mit, was der Pisspass neulich ganz wunderbar beschrieben hat, dass er gesagt hat, wenn wir Exportweltmeister sind, dann muss es irgendwo auch einen Importweltmeister geben. Und der ist halt Griechenland. Und wir haben dafür gesorgt, dass sie das kaufen, weil unsere Wirtschaft vom Export abhängt. Und wir haben denen einfach die Kohle, die wir hatten, als Kredit gegeben, weil wir gesagt haben, es ist immer noch besser, wenn die alle platzen, als wenn unsere Wirtschaft jetzt platzt. Denn in der Politik denkt man ja immer so vier Jahre, Merkel hat überlebt bis zur nächsten Wahl, müssen wir überleben, ach naja, die Kohle können wir den Griechen schon leihen. Denn wenn die Kredite platzen, platzen sie in der nächsten Legislaturperiode. Und dass die da immer noch an der Macht sein würde, das wusste die halt nicht. So ist mein irgendwie Denken, wie das zu dieser ganzen Situation kam. Und jetzt irgendwie wird das halt so dargestellt, als wenn es die Schuld der Griechen ist, dass die die Kredite genommen haben, die wir ihnen hingeworfen haben.
Plus die Frage am Ende ist ja, können sie daraus einen neuen Stabilitätsnarrativ konstruieren? Letztendlich wird derjenige gewinnen nach der Krise, der am glaubhaftesten versprechen kann, wieder Stabilität zu erzeugen.
Na das macht die Merkel ja, indem sie einfach nix sagt zu den meisten Themen. Und dann können immer irgendwelche anderen Leute...
Das würde aber an irgendeinem Punkt nicht mehr gehen.
Du, da warte ich seit zehn Jahren drauf. Das kann ich nicht beobachten, dass es irgendwann nicht mehr geht. Ich würde mich ja sehr freuen, wenn es irgendwann nicht mehr geht, aber ich sehe da keine Anhaltspunkte für.
Na gut, Deutschland ist vielleicht auch noch in gewisser Art und Weise ein Sonderfall, aber auch hier ist durchaus vorstellbar, dass innerhalb relativ kurzer Zeit der Narrativ dieses ein Rent schaffe schaffe Häusle baue, Kapitalismus halt irgendwie gegen die Wand fährt. Also wenn die Leute unseren Scheiß nicht mehr kaufen können, dann ist hier irgendwie auch ganz schnell Zappenduster.
Ich glaube, das ist schon geschehen. Und was wir jetzt sehen, sind die Gegenmaßnahmen, die eingeleitet wurden. Dass wir Griechenland einfach egal Kredite gegeben haben, egal wie hoch, obwohl wir wussten, dass wir das nicht zurückzahlen können. Einfach, damit es jemanden gibt, der unseren Scheiß kauft. Und nicht nur Griechenland, Italien, Spanien. Das wussten wir doch, dass die davon keine eigene Industrie aufbauen, die konkurrenzfähig ist. Sonst hätten wir es doch nicht gemacht. Dann hätten wir ja mit denen konkurrieren müssen. Das geht ja nicht. Das wäre auch schlecht für unsere Wirtschaft gewesen. Das ist ja kein Zufall, dass sich das so entwickelt hat, wie es jetzt entwickelt ist. Dass wir die alle als Konsumenten halten, weil die nicht mit uns mithalten können. Und ab und zu verkaufen wir eine Lizenz für eine Waffenfabrik, die dann irgendwo gebaut wird. Aber das ist die Ausnahme. Normalerweise verkaufen wir unsere Produkte.
Und wenn es als schief geht, nehmen wir die profitablen Flughäfen.
Genau, und am Ende nehmen wir die Flughäfen. Also ich glaube, dass nichts von dem, was wir in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren gesehen haben, Zufall ist. Sondern das sind alles schon die Gegenstrategien, um den Verfall aufzuhalten, damit es nicht so aussieht.
Denn wenn man sich die Reallöhne ansieht, dann gibt es auch diese Rede von Gizzi von damals.
Wo er das komplett einmal vorhergesagt hat.
Wenn wir uns mal so 2008 angucken, es gab ja diese Occupy-Bewegung, die unter anderem auch deswegen so hart verfolgt wurde, weil sie den Narrativ des alternativlosen Globalkapitalismus in Frage gestellt hat. Das war ja einer der Gründe, weswegen wir so viel Stress bekommen haben. Also dass wir halt irgendwie sich nicht mehr an den normalen Narrativ gehalten haben. Und dann sind die halt aus den üblichen Gründen kaputtgegangen. Sie waren halt keine wirklich Bewegung, sind halt, haben sich zu viele Spinner darauf eingenistet, das übliche. Die Frage ist, ob es beim nächsten Mal genauso klappt, also ob sie noch irgendwie Mittel und Methoden haben, um die Opposition runterzufahren, um die Opposition runterzufahren und dafür zu sorgen, dass es irgendwie weitergeht. Oder ob wir dann halt schon gegen den Baum fahren.
Ich glaube, dass wir dafür stocken die jetzt die ganze Überwachung von solche Medien auf.
Nicht nur die Überwachung des Militär. Das ganze Gelabere, was wir hatten, dass die Bundeswehr schlecht ausgerüstet ist und im Notfall auch im Inland irgendwie tätig werden muss, das ist meines Erachtens die Vorbereitung für die nächste Runde der Krisenpolitik. Wenn es hier platzt, dann müssen wir dafür sorgen, dass wir einfach genug Polizeistaat haben.
Aber ich glaube, das fängt nicht an mit Militär, das fängt an mit Social Media Überwachung.
Na klar.
Sehr, sehr genau und sehr gezielt.
Nein, aber die sind durchaus...
Im Endeffekt willst du eine 8-Bit Unsigned Integer für Obedience, für die ganze Bevölkerung.
Ja, aber du musst ja auch eine Keule haben dahinter. Da muss ja mehr als irgendwie soziale...
Aber umso genauer du die ganze Bevölkerung gescord hast, umso weniger Keule brauchst du.
Na klar. Aber ich bin zunehmend dabei, die Welt um mich rum durch diese Brille zu betrachten, einfach zu sagen, okay, das ist jetzt schon wieder eine Krisenvorbereitung oder Gegenhandlung. Was war denn die Krise dabei? Was wird denn hier konkret? Weil viele von den Sachen, die sind ja nicht doof in der Politik, sondern die haben ja Strategien, die ihnen sagen, wo es hingeht und was man jetzt tun müsste, um es zu verhindern.
Es gibt mehrere Schichten von Zukunftgucken für die Leute, die da reingeholt werden, um zu sagen, was wird dann passieren in den ganzen Ministerien. Und die, die so 10 oder 15 oder 20 Jahre vorausgucken, die kommen teilweise mit immer dunkleren Geschichten.
Was sagen die denn so?
Also die gleichen Sachen, die Frank und ich sagen, wenn wir aufs Podium sitzen irgendwo, die sagen dann so, ach du, wird alles scheiße und Klimawandel und Menschenmassen, hunderte Millionen Menschen auf der Flüchtung. Und geht alles den Bach runter. Und was denkst du, das Politiker machen, wenn alle, die über 10, 15 Jahre hinausgucken, sagen, ja, es könnte mal gut den Bach runtergehen. Dann fangt man an, Zaune zu bauen, da fangt man an.
Wir müssen auch noch einen Zaun zu den Niederlanden bauen, sonst kommen die auch nicht zu uns, wenn der Meeresstiegel stärkt.
Ein Deich.
Ja, super.
Der Plan für Niederlande ist eigentlich klar. Wir schenken ihnen einfach mehr Klamuck Vorpaum an, haben alle was von.
Super. So läuft's.
Na gut, wollen wir mal versuchen, so ein bisschen positiver zu denken.
Ich habe eigentlich gerade versucht, so einen Übergang zu bauen zu dem nächsten Punkt, den ich auf meiner Liste habe, nämlich, dass ich zu beobachten glaube, dass die Konflikte alle immer militärischer werden. Das ist einfach immer...
Das betrachtest du als positiv?
Nein, nicht positiv. Aber es ist einfach ein viel schneller benutztes Mittel heute, ein gezielt getimtes Manöver zu machen, jetzt in Korea gerade gut zu beobachten. Da gab es irgendwelche Grenzstreitigkeiten, die gibt es seit was, so lang es die Grenze da gibt, zwischen Nord und Südkorea, pisaken die sich. Aber diesmal ist es irgendwie so ein bisschen entgleist, als Nordkorea dann Artillerie in der demilitarisierten Zone stationiert hat und dann haben die Amis... Dann haben die Amis mit Südkorea ein fettes Manöver gemacht und da gab es dann ein Video von auf YouTube und das hat mir ja fast die Schuhe ausgezogen.
Dieses Command und Conquer Briefing Video?
Es gab zwei Videos, die ausdaren wie so ein Command und Conquer Video. Das eine war ein NATO-Ding, das war also original mit so tumpen Blöden pro Kriegssprüchen und dieses Südkorea-Video, das sah tatsächlich aus wie so die Einleitung vom Videospiel. Also die schießen jetzt hier rauf und die schießen darauf. Das war wie so ein Videospiel, aber nicht nur von der Optik, sondern auch unterlegt mit so einer Kriegsteilbarischen Videospielmusik. Der Übergang zwischen so ATS, Command und Conquer-Style-Spielen und diesen Militärvideos, die gerade produziert werden, ist immer fließender. Auch in der Ukraine ist ja sofort irgendwie Militärkram gewesen. Das ist ja sehr schnell entgleist. Also das ist mein Eindruck, dass wir einfach immer schneller zum Militär greifen, weil wir einfach die Hemmungen abgebaut haben.
Das heißt also, du würdest sagen, dass...
Daher glaube ich auch, dass das Militär im Inland demnächst eine Option sein wird.
Also du meinst sozusagen, eigentlich ist die Vision eines nutzerfreundlichen Überwachungsstaates irgendwie noch eine positive Vision, weil wir dann zumindest keine Militärreglatur haben.
Das ist besser, als wenn uns das Militär platzschießt, ja.
Wollten wir nicht eigentlich gerade positiver werden? Wollten wir eigentlich, aber...
On this positive note...
Die Frage ist halt, wie könnte denn ein alterativer Narrativ aussehen?
Es gibt auch positive Aspekte. Es ist nicht alles scheiße. Also zum Beispiel eine Sache, die mich total überrascht hat, war, dass D-E-Mail jetzt plötzlich PGP anbietet. Wo ich überhaupt nicht mitgerechnet hab, dass es da irgendeinen Einlenken gibt.
Und D-E-Mail nicht. Die Provider bieten gerade PGP-Mail an D-E-Mail?
Und D-E-Mail auch.
Was?
Ja, offiziell. Du kannst jetzt Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselungen mit D-E-Mail haben.
Boah, das war aber zu nerdy, ey.
Nein, aber also, dass es an dieser Front überhaupt Bewegung geben würde. Denn D-E-Mail hat ja gerade die Vision gehabt, dass du den Staat schon traust und die können deine Mails entschlüsseln und es ist irgendwie gleich groß.
Ja, es gibt die ganze Welt geht unter und ist nicht gleich groß.
Aber ich greife hier noch den kleinen Strohhalm. Und das ist einer der kleinen Strohhalme, wo ich dachte so.
Richtig nerdy kleinen Strohhalm.
Jetzt gibt es aber doch. Nein, es gibt aber Bewegung an der Krypto-Front und zwar in unsere Richtung. Das fand ich erstaunlich, denn es sah nicht so aus, als wenn wir irgendwas weisen können bei Krypto. Eher im Gegenteil, als wenn es jetzt immer schlimmer wird.
Wenn wir uns die Debatte in USA angucken.
Das wird auch gerade immer schlimmer in USA, ne?
Du warst ja gerade da, erzähl doch mal.
Ja, also es ist nicht so in die öffentliche Diskussion, aber die Nerd-Foreign kriegen es natürlich alle mit. Also wer danach guckt, merkt, dass gerade die Politik zusehends von Silicon Valley verlangt, dass es einen entschlüsselnden Zugang zu allen Kommunikationen geben muss, wegen der Terroristen. Und Silicon Valley sagt bisher nein und so einen richtigen Druck haben sie noch nicht, aber man kann es natürlich von außen nicht sagen, ob es die nicht schon alle gibt, diese Schnittstellen, denn es gibt ja die National Security Letters und denen musst du halt folgen, man kann es keinem davon erzählen. Also das ist schon so eine etwas bedrückende Lage, dass man einfach davon ausgehen muss, dass die doch schon alles mitschnorcheln. Und bei Snowden kam ja auch aus, dass sie einfach, wo sie nicht freiwillig reingelassen wurden, da gehen sie halt an die Fasern.
Ist denn da der Einfluss des Silicon Valley in der Politik schon zu merken?
Welcher Politik?
Ist der Einfluss des Silicon Valley in der Politik da schon zu merken?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Politiker stehen sehr darauf, sich mit irgendwelchen Silicon Valley-Firmen, und da wird jetzt auch mal so was wie Uber dazuzählen, irgendwie in der Öffentlichkeit zu zeigen, weil das als progressiv, das ist so der letzte Aspekt in der Wirtschaft, wo Amerika noch führend ist, außer Waffenbau. Also das ist ihnen schon aufgefallen, dass das wichtig ist. Und sie kümmern sich darum und es gab, oh wo war es denn, es gab vor Jahren diesen großartigen Artikel, also was Silicon Valley im Gegensatz zu den anderen Industrien jahrelang nicht gemacht hat, ist Lobbyisten nach Washington schicken, weil sie einfach die Nerds generell gesagt haben, ja diese Politik, das ist alles irgendwie, das ist scheiße, da kümmern wir uns nicht drum. Und das hat eben dazu geführt, dass die Politik angefangen hat, demonstrativ Microsoft ein Kartellverfahren an den Hals zu hängen, was dann irgendwie Jahre lief. Und daraufhin hat Microsoft natürlich Fettlobbyismus noch umgetrieben und dann war das plötzlich weg, das Verfahren. Ich hab das ja alles erlebt, die Aspekte davon, aber ich hab das nie so in Zusammenhang gelegt. Und Apple hat dann auch mal so einen Wink mit einem Zornfall gekriegt, so hör mal zu, hier gieß es dann auch plötzlich. Irgendwelche Federal Agencies würden irgendwelche Untersuchungen los treten. Und Apple hat jetzt auch fette Lobbying-Kapazität. Google zahlt inzwischen Fett für Lobbying. Also die sind mehr denn je in einem Boot, jetzt die Politik und Silicon Valley. Aber es heißt eben auch, dass die Politik auch keine Hemmungen hat, denen zu sagen, hör mal zu Leute, ihr müsst da jetzt uns ranlassen. Bisher gibt es noch keine Stories darüber, dass das irgendwie geglückt ist, außer halt diese NSA-Geschichten. So Yahoo und so, das ist ja wohl ziemlich komplett.
Der Narrativ?
Ja. Aber gut, das zählt, finde ich, nicht so, weil das ja eigentlich fast ein Staatsunternehmen war damals. Das war ja noch vor dem...
Aber der Narrativ des Silicon Valley ist ja eigentlich immer noch, anstatt der neueren Silicon Valley-Konzerne, die Politik kriegt das nicht hin. Wir müssen da mal andere Lösungen dafür finden.
Und das kann die Politik natürlich überhaupt nicht leiden, deswegen versucht sie sich da rein zu dringeln.
Der Wahlkampf in Usa ist ja, wie soll ich es heutzutage formulieren, nicht direkt sachorientiert.
Nee, aber der ist im Moment auf einer Ebene bizarr, wie wir es noch nicht erlebt haben. Also ich kann mich jedenfalls nicht erinnern, dass jemand so erlebt zu haben, dass wir jetzt sowohl bei den Republikanern als auch bei den Demokraten einen Kandidaten aus dem Nichts haben, der da wie der Phoenix aus der Asche hervorsteigt und die komplette Aufmerksamkeit auf sich zentralisiert. Also bei den Demokraten war völlig klar, Hillary steht an und da musste gar nicht mehr antreten dagegen, weil so offensichtlich wird die Präsidentin oder zumindest Kandidatin der Demokraten. Und dann kommt dieser Bernie Sanders, ein Altkommunist aus Vermont.
Also aus US-Sicht die Altkommunist.
Aus US-Sicht ist das jemand, der mal in den 50ern irgendwie eingelocht hätte. Ja, so jemand. Und der damals mit Martin Luther King an irgendwelchen Menschenrechtsmärschen– also eine Figur völlig unter Ferner liefen im US-Politik-Tagesgeschäft. Normalerweise wird immer nur belächelt. Und der zieht plötzlich da bei seinen Veranstaltungen Crowds, wo die dann in ein Fußballstadium umziehen müssen, womit 20.000 Sitzplätzen und dann gibt's immer noch eine Schlange vorm Eingang und 7.000 kommen nicht rein. Also der hat da plötzlich ein Interesse mit seinem Kram geweckt, dass die Hillary-Zahlen immer schlechter sind. Sogar in den Swing-States sind die jetzt eher bei 30 und sie bei 37 Prozent. Also Hillary muss sich ernsthaft Sorgen machen, dass sie die Kandidatin der Demokraten wird. Das war absolut nicht abzusehen. Und das ist so weit, dass die Presse immer nur über Bernie Sanders jetzt berichtet. Der hat hier eine Veranstaltung gemacht, da kamen so viele Leute. Dann hat er da eine Veranstaltung gemacht, da kamen so viele Leute. Und Hillary kommt überhaupt mit ihren Botschaften gar nicht in die...
Na gut, sie hat ja auch keine. Außer es ist gut, dass diese Mails verschwunden sind.
Wenn mal was kommt von Hillary, dann sind es nur so Schadensbegrenzungen wie dieser Mail-Server. Von Hillary kam noch nichts, wo sie ihre Botschaft hätte positionieren können. Und sie hat vielleicht auch gar keine Botschaft, weil es so klar aussah, dass sie die Kandidatin würde.
Also das ist jedenfalls ein... Hillary hatte sich ja eigentlich mehr auf diesen Personality-Wahlkampf spezialisiert. Die hatte ja eigentlich keine Aussagen, außer ich bin eine Frau.
Und ich habe Erfahrung.
Und ich komme aus dem klaren Halb. Und Trump auf der anderen Seite, der sozusagen der andere...
Und Trump ist der andere, der aus dem Nichts kam, wo alle gesagt haben, ha ha ha ha ha.
Aber das ist sozusagen das laufende Toupet. Das Polar Opposite zu Sanders. Also im Sinne von... Bei Sanders macht er primär Sachwahlkampf. Der hat's ja nicht so sehr mit dem...
Der macht nur Sachwahlkampf. Der weigert sich förmlich, irgendwie Sachen über andere Kandidaten zu sagen, wenn er danach gefragt wird und sagt, ich bin hergekommen, um meine politischen...
Genau, er macht keine negative Werbung. Genau.
Trump und Sanders haben eine Sache gemeinsam. Nämlich, sie claimen beide, und ich glaube zu Recht, sie claimen beide, ich werde nicht von irgendwelchen Lobbyisten gesteuert. Und das stimmt, und das muss man auch sehen. Dass die Wähler, ob sie jetzt Trump oder Sanders bevorzügen, aber die Wähler gehen jetzt massiv in Richtung von Leuten, die halbwegs glaubt, würde ich sagen.
Wir haben keinen Bock mehr auf diese ganzen...
Auf jeden Fall ist es nicht nur eine Funktion von wieviel Geld, von welcher Richtung auf mein Konto fließt, welche Aussagen ich hier tätige.
Das ist die zentrale Aussage von Trump, ich bin ja schon so reich, ich brauche keine Bestechung mehr. Und Trump ist ja seit vielen Jahren...
Sanders sagt, alles kommt in mehrfachen 30 Dollar Donations rein, und ich bin auch nicht bestechlich im Sinne von... Beide Richtungen sind in Richtung von nicht bestechlich, ob man das jetzt mag oder nicht, aber...
Das heißt also, die wollen einfach keinen mehr haben, der aus dem System kommt.
Genau, sind halt nicht im System.
Ja. Wobei Trump ist natürlich schon im System. Also der hat ja diese lustige... Bei dieser Republikaner-Debatte hat er sich hingestellt und diese großartige Rede gehalten, wo er meinte, also wenn ich mir hier meine Mitkandidaten ansehe, die haben alle schon Geld von mir genommen für ihren Wahlkampf. So, und dann meinten so, bis auf zwei. Und dann meint er, also ich nicht, meint der eine so, aber die alle anderen konnten es nicht leugnen. Also der US-Wahlkampf funktioniert eben so, dass der Kandidate selber bezahlen muss. Nicht wie in Deutschland, wo man nach der Wahl, nach dem Ergebnis irgendwie Kohle zurückkriegt, um seine Plakatierung da zu bezahlen. Das heißt im Wesentlichen heißt Wahlkampf rumlaufen und Kohle sammeln. Und das macht auch Trump, obwohl er auf der einen Seite erzählt, er sei ja so reich und braucht keine Kohle, kam jetzt irgendwie raus, dass er 100 Dollar Eintritt für seine Auftritte nimmt.
Ja, zumindest bei diesem einen Auftritt. Und sein Argument war ja, dass der auch so viel Geld gekostet hätte, das wäre halt nur Cost Covering gewesen.
Ja, ist ja egal.
Na ja, gut, okay.
Entweder du bist reich oder du bist nicht reich. Aber Trump hat schon so viel in den Sand gesetzt, ist auch egal. Aber jedenfalls Trump, eine absolute Witzfigur vor dem Wahlkampf. Und Sanders, ein Außenseiter, wie es Außenseitiger im Grunde gar nicht geht. Und die beiden sind jetzt plötzlich die glaubwürdigen Kandidaten der jeweiligen Parteien, also noch nicht offiziell. Aber Jeb Bush stinkt total ab, der galt als der klare Kandidat der Republikaner. Und Hilary ist zwar in den Umfragen noch vorne, aber nur ein ganz kleines bisschen, ja. Das ist echt unglaublich, der Wahlkampf gerade, wie der läuft. Da kann man sich nur wünschen, dass es ja auch mal so ein paar Umbrüche gibt. Einfach, dass man hier mal die Wahl zwischen mehr als einem Kanzlerkandidaten der jeweiligen Partei hat. Das finde ich mal einen Fortschritt, muss ich sagen.
Weil das einzige, was mich daran nervt, ist, dass dieser Wahlkampf in Ameland so schrecklich nervt.
Ja, aber das musste als, was sich nicht ändern kann, ist Entertainment. So musst du da ran gehen.
Ja, und es gibt keine Daily-Show mehr, was diese halt echt schwierig macht.
Ja, die kommt bald wieder mit Trevor Noah. Der wird jetzt ganz lustig.
Okay, wollen wir hoffen.
Na gut.
Aber die Frage ist halt, wird das irgendwas an den Problemen der Welt ändern? Nein, ne?
Nein, aber das ist trotzdem ein wichtiges Signal, weil, ob es jetzt Trump oder Sen das wird, Trump hat jetzt gerade gesagt am Rande in einem Interview, er findet ja, die Hedge-Farm-Manager machen zu viel Kohle und zahlen zu wenig Steuern. Das müsste man jetzt mal die Reichen besteuern.
Aber sind das nicht seine Kumpels?
Eigentlich ja. Eigentlich sind Hedge-Farm-Manager genau die Leute, die so auf Republikana blablabla stehen. Aber am Ende ist New York immer in Demokratenhand, obwohl da die ganzen Trader wohnen. Also das ist so ein bisschen zwiegespalten. Das heißt immer, die Demokraten sind mit den Wall-Street-Leuten im Bett. Aber auf der anderen Seite versuchen die Republikaner, sich da natürlich ranzuwerfen und sind die Partei für die Besserverdienenden. Aber wenn selbst Trump sagt, wir müssen jetzt mal die Mittelklasse entlasten.
Aber das Mittelklasse-entlasten-Ding sagen sie alle.
Aber Trump sagt eben auch, wir müssen jetzt mal die Reichen besteuern. Das ist ein Erdbeben.
Will not happen, würde ich sagen.
Ja, würde mich auch wundern. Aber wenn jetzt beide Kandidaten, also Sender sagt das natürlich sowieso, und macht damit Durchmarsch bei seinen potenziellen Wählern, weil Hillary sagt, ist eben nicht offen, dass sie jetzt mal gegen die Banker was machen will. Und plötzlich hat man zumindest das Gefühl, dass da Optionen offen sind in diesem Wahlkampf, was ja sonst eher nicht der Fall ist. Sondern dass ein Kandidat, der ist meh und ein Kandidat, der ist, oh mein Gott, hoffentlich wird es dir nicht. Aber diesmal hat man also erstmalig, fand ich, den Eindruck, dass es da auch mal ein positives Outcome geben könnte.
Na ja, Frank hat gesagt, was passiert und was werden die Narratives? Und was passiert, wenn der Militärstaat jetzt, kommt das jetzt dem Militär auf der Straße oder kriegen wir jetzt so eine mehr subtile Polizeistaat? Und was für positives können wir da gegenüber setzen? Ich glaube, es fängt alles an, damit dass wir glauben. Und das hat auch mit dieser Besteuerung der Reichen zu tun. Glauben wir jetzt langsam, dass der Welt zero sum ist, dass Wachstum nicht ewig ist? Kriegen wir das jetzt in die Köpfe der Bevölkerung, the people at large kriegen wir das jetzt rein? Dass Wachstum nicht aus dem Nichts kommt, dass die Welt jetzt langsam alle ist? Der Tag, dass wir jetzt einen Planeten an resources benutzt haben, ist jetzt schon im Sommer. Kriegen wir das hin, wenn wir das hinbekommen, wenn wir hinbekommen, dass die Leute verstehen, dass eigentlich nur noch zero sum ist und dass wir eigentlich de facto nur noch über Verteilung reden. De facto. Wie wir es jetzt nennen ist egal, aber alle Debatten ab jetzt gehen nur noch über Verteilung.
Man kann argumentieren, dass das schon länger so ist, dass wir es nur nicht sehen, weil wir das andere Leuten in anderen Ländern wegnehmen und nicht uns.
Genau das meine ich. Aber jetzt sind wir zumindest auf dem Punkt, wo es offensichtlich wird, wo wir nicht mehr irgendwo Wald abholzen können oder Ozean leer fischen können.
Aber ist das nicht mit den Kolonien schon so gewesen, dass man bei uns kein Wachstum mehr hatte und dann mussten wir eben in Afrika und...
Ja, aber es geht halt jetzt eben nicht mehr.
Wenn es alle war, haben wir auf drei Arten reagiert. Menschen, schon seit es Menschen gibt. Entweder wir sind irgendwo anders hingegangen, um deren Sachen zu klauen, oder wir sind selber dahin umgezogen, oder wir sind ausgestorben im Lokal. Und jetzt haben wir das gleiche Problem, nur planetär. Also die ersten zwei Lösungen gibt es jetzt nicht. Wir können nicht irgendwo anders hin und deren Sachen klauen, weil das Problem ist jetzt planetär. Wir können nicht dahin umziehen, weil Mars, es gibt nichts nebenan, wo wir hinziehen können. Können wir aussterben, oder wir können zumindest versuchen, so lange wie es nur geht, damit umzugehen, dass es jetzt zero sum ist. Und ich glaube, das ist die Kulturwandel, die wir jetzt brauchen. Ob wir das hinbekommen, ist eine offene Frage.
Vor allen Dingen ist die Frage, um es zu bekommen, ob man daraus einen Stabilitätsnarrativ ableiten kann, wo Leute für sich persönlich sagen, okay, das ist ein Lebensstil, mit dem kann ich klar kommen, da sind meine Bedürfnisse irgendwie gedeckt und der sieht so aus, als wäre der irgendwie hinreichend, long term stable, dass ich zumindest meine Kinder groß kriege, was ja der Grundbedarf der meisten Leute ist.
Das heißt, die Finanzmärkte müssen umgebaut, weil die gehen alle von brisanten Wachstum aus. Ja, das Zinssystem an sich. Da müssen wir ganz viel umbauen, aber so ein Zero Growth Economy. Und zumindest die Gedankenanregungen da hinzukommen, die Gedanken, dass das notwendig wäre.
Ich mache mir große Sorgen, wenn ich das höre, weil das ist so der Nährboden für anderen Leuten vorschreiben, wie viel Kinder sie haben dürfen. Und zu sagen, okay, dann müssen wir die Flüchtlinge jetzt aber nicht durchfüttern, weil dann, wenn die sterben, haben wir mehr für den Rest von uns. Also diese Art von Gedanken kommen.
Das ist eine Richtung, aber es gibt auch andere Richtungen. Du kannst auch in positive Richtungen versuchen zu denken, mindestens. Aber zumindest auf der gleiche Grundlage, dass jetzt Wachstum, so wie wir es hatten, dass das eine Phase war, die hat uns gebracht, wo wir sind. Das ist auch nicht alles schlecht, deswegen. Aber wir müssen diese Phase jetzt langsam zuschauen, dass der langsam vorbei ist. Dieses Wachstum, zumindest so wie wir es hatten, geht nicht mehr. Nicht ohne, dass wir, ohne weitere große technische Fortschritte, die die ganze Grundlagen anders machen, geht dieses Wachstum auf jeden Fall nicht mehr. Ob jetzt China, ob jetzt überall, egal. Wir können versuchen, noch mehr Wald abzuholzen, um es noch mal fünf Jahre länger zu halten. Wir können noch ein bisschen mehr Fracking betreiben, um zu tun, als wäre die Lage nicht so, wie sie ist. Aber wir müssen zu so einem Verständnis hin. Und da kann man auf jeden Fall in allerhand negativen Richtungen denken. Aber wir müssen versuchen, die positiven Richtungen für die gleiche Grundlage zu finden.
Dann nenne doch mal einen positiven Aspekt. Ich sehe immer nur, ich sehe nur die...
Wir können anfangen nachzudenken, wie wir eine Wirtschaft bauen, die nicht von diesem Wachstum abhängig ist. Das wäre schon mal ein Anfang. Weil diese Wachstum wird es demnächst nicht mehr geben. Und wir können das mit Crash erleben.
Wachstum wird es schon noch geben, aber auf Kosten anderer eben. Also du kannst wachsen, indem du deine Konkurrenten plant machst. Du kannst deren Geschäft übernehmen, aber du kannst halt nicht Wachstum dazu generieren.
Das ist ein bestimmter Punkt. Aber die Weltwirtschaft geht jetzt davon aus, dass es Bruttowachstum gibt.
Ja gut, aber Fefe hat schon recht. Also der einzige Weg für dich persönlich, Wachstum zu erzeugen, dann ist halt auf Kosten anderer. Also nicht mehr auf Kosten des Planeten.
Wie Fefe auch schon gesagt hat, das ist schon eine Weile so.
Also nicht mehr auf Kosten des Planeten, was ja bisher der einzige Weg war, wirklich Wachstum zu erzeugen, sondern...
Naja, aber das riecht doch alles schon nach Ayn Rand, irgendwie Argumentation, dass dann jeder nur noch an sich denkt. Das Kollektive und Soziale...
Ayn Rand ist nicht, dass jeder an sich denkt, sondern Ayn Rand geht noch einen Schritt weiter. Jeder denkt an sich und daraus kommt was Gutes. Ja, nee, aber das ist Psychopathie.
Ich glaube, dass der komplette Ansatz, dass wir uns um andere Menschen kümmern, auf dem Weg bleibt, wenn wir von einer Welt ausgehen, in der nicht genug für alle da ist und wir Mangelmanagement machen.
Nicht genug für alle ist nicht mal wahr. Nur, wir müssen die Grundlagen, worauf wir das System jetzt gebaut haben, jetzt umdenken, während wir noch können. Weil die Möglichkeiten umzudenken, nehmen ab, nicht zu.
Tatsächlich ist genug für alle da.
Ja, im Moment, aber die Menschheit wächst und wächst.
Genau, also müssen wir jetzt nachdenken, wie wir es umbauen und nicht, wenn die Krise kommt.
Wenn wir keinen Handlungsspielraum mehr haben.
Na und wie soll das aussehen?
Ja, genau.
Das ist die interessante Frage.
Genau.
So, damit steht und fällt die Sache, aber ob es gelingt, ein Narrativ aufzubauen, der so klingt, als könnte funktionieren. Und dazu gehört halt zum einen Wirtschaftssystem, so zum anderen aber natürlich halt auch die Frage, wie funktioniert es für die Leute individuell? Also wie sieht halt irgendwie, ist es halt ein Sozialismussystem im schlimmsten aller Designs, was halt irgendwie im Wesentlichen eine Initiative irgendwie nicht mehr mag und irgendwie nur noch Verteilung macht? Oder wird es sowas wie das chinesische System der harmonischen Gesellschaft, die halt wohl definierte kleine enge Stellen von Eigeninitiative und So viel ist Common Sense.
Wir können heute aufhören Kohle zu subventionieren. Wir können heute anfangen Verbrennungsmotoren irgendwie langsam abzuschaffen. So viel ist Common Sense.
Also da kann man vielleicht auch direkt mal was positives ableiten, dass man sagt, okay, wenn wir nicht mehr auf Wachstum bauen, dann müssen wir auch nicht mehr produzieren, als gebraucht wird.
Als erstes schaffen wir erstmal die Werbeindustrie ab.
Genau. Und diverse Sachen sind dann plötzlich einfach. Dann gibt es keine Entschuldigung mehr für Überproduktion. Wenn du sagst, wir haben hier kein Wachstum, auf das wir uns vorbereiten. Und dann kannst du nämlich auch sagen, dann müssen wir alle weniger arbeiten. Das ist vielleicht ein positiver Aspekt, den man da empfiehlt.
De facto ist es ja nicht so, dass wir uns nicht eine Wirtschaft vorstellen könnten, die so funktioniert. Also wir haben die Daten. Wir könnten tatsächlich eine Planwirtschaft machen, die sich nicht anrückt. Heutzutage ist es ja schon so, dass gerade die Großkonzerne in erheblichem Maße Forecasting und Planning machen, auf der Basis der Daten, die wir aus dem Netz haben. Und wenn man diese Art zu wirtschaften, tatsächlich die Ermittlung von Bedürfnissen, nicht die Erzeugung von Bedürfnissen in den Mittelpunkt stellt, dann kann man halt schon so etwas wie einen Kommunismus bauen mit dem Technologiestand, den wir heute haben. Also im Sinne von Kommunismus, im Sinne von der urtypischen Idealdefinition zu sagen, jeden nach seinen Bedürfnissen. Also jeder kriegt das, was er braucht und trägt halt bei, was er beitragen kann. Die Möglichkeit, was die Technologielevel angeht, haben wir. Wir müssen halt nur mal aufhören, den ganzen Scheiß zu machen. Also ich meine, wenn du allein überlegst, die Kohle, die die Amis jedes Jahr in ihr Militär buttern, wurde ausreichen, innerhalb von fünf Jahren das weltweite Energieproblem zu lösen.
Ja und den Welthunger habe ich als Vergleich gesehen auch gut.
Dann könnte man halt einfach mit Solarzahlen und Wind und what not irgendwie einfach erledigen das Problem. Wir bräuchten halt keinen Fossilflug mehr, müssten halt nur aufhören, diese Flugzeugträger durch die Gegend zu fahren. Also es ist nicht so, dass es technisch keine Möglichkeiten dazu gäbe, es ist halt nur die Art und Weise, wie wir denken und wie wir halt unsere Politik betreiben und uns daran gewöhnt haben, die Wirtschaft als normal zu sehen.
Na gut, aber ich sehe auch einen moralischen Umschwung kommen dann, weil wenn ich mir sage, ok im Moment, wenn ich jetzt mehr arbeite als ich muss, dann tue ich das irgendwie für Wachstum und Aufschwung. Also ob das jetzt war, ist nicht sagen wir dahingestellt, aber das ist jedenfalls, kann ich mir schönreden, dass ich sage, ok das hat einen Sinn. In Zukunft ist das aber, ok wenn ich jetzt mehr arbeite, dann ist das zulasten jemand anderes. Das ist also inherent unmoralisch. Also ich denke, da werden sich einige Sachen ändern, wie wir Dinge betrachten.
Na gut, ich meine, du nimmst halt an einem Roboter die Arbeit weg.
Also viele Sachen in unserer Wirtschaft sind ja, weil wir von Wachstum ausgehen, Hypotheken auf die Zukunft. Sachen, die wir noch nicht eingenommen haben, von deren Eintreten wir aber fest ausgehen. Und wenn das wegfällt, fällt einfach mal ein signifikanter Teil weg, den wir gar nicht damit assoziieren im Moment. Ich glaube, das wird das größte Problem werden, die größte Umstellung. Weil im Moment kannst du einfach sagen, ok ich investiere jetzt hier, weil dieses Unternehmen wird ja wachsen.
Naja, kann ja weiter passieren.
Wir kommen dann irgendwann zu einem Punkt, wo du nur noch investierst, um entweder neue Technologien zu entwickeln oder um alte Sachen zu reparieren.
Oder abzulösen.
Durch neue Technologien, ja.
Also ich meine, das ist halt inhärent eine Wirtschaft, die halt wesentlich innovationsfreundlicher und innovationsnotwendiger ist. Also in der es halt einfach neue Optimierungsziele gibt, nämlich einfach weniger Ressourcen zu verbrauchen, um irgendwie trotzdem wenigstens denselben Komfort oder einen größeren Komfort irgendwie zu haben. Und das finde ich eigentlich persönlich ganz geil. Kommt dem Ingenieursgeist ja sehr entgegen so als Ziel. Nur muss man halt eben das Optimierungsziel, mehr Geld zu verdienen durch das Optimierungsziel, weniger Ressourcen verbrauchen. Das ist halt eigentlich eine relativ einfache Änderung so.
Ich sehe aber auch einen Zielkonflikt, weil wir auf der einen Seite immer als Visionen handeln durch die ganzen Computer und Roboter, die unsere Arbeit machen. Ich kann jetzt weniger arbeiten. Irgendwann muss ich vielleicht gar nicht mehr arbeiten, weil das irgendwie die Maschinen für mich machen. Das heißt, wir kommen weg von diesem alle sind meine Konkurrenten und wir sitzen eigentlich und die Roboter machen das für uns. Aber wenn wir jetzt eine Ressourcenverwaltung ohne Wachstum haben, dann sind ja alle Akte inhärent Konkurrenz mit anderen Leuten. Also das stelle ich mir an sich sehr negativ vor. Ist heute schon so, aber heute kann ich mir das irgendwie schönreden oder ignorieren.
Eigentlich ist es so, dass nur in der Ressourcen-Extrionindustrie, also Bergbau und Energie, ist die Konkurrenz nur darum, wer schneller den Hügel wegbuggern kann.
Na in vielen Bereichen der IT-Industrie ist es so, dass der Markt schneller wächst, als die bestehenden Marktteilnehmer sie befüllen können. Das heißt, da gibt es noch so Situationen wie im Bergbau, dass du sagst, ich nehme niemandem was weg, wenn ich wachse. Aber das wird in Zukunft dann immer seltener werden, sondern nur noch, wenn es echte Innovationen irgendwo gibt.
Na gut, aber das ist ja im Rest der Industrie heute schon so.
Tja, gut, das betrifft mich jetzt persönlich als den Rest, aber das ist eigentlich eher ein Horror für mich, die Idee, dass man nur noch jeder Akt, den ich irgendwie mache, ist dann nur noch Konkurrenz.
Aber selbst in der IT-Industrie ist das ja so. Die Ginko-Systemplays der großen Spieler sind ja nichts anderes als Versuche, dem Konkurrenten Luft abzudrehen, indem sie das, was der Konkurrent für Geld macht, umsonst machen. Also de facto ist das halt nur die nächste Stufe des Konkurses.
Oder zu versuchen, die besten Leute wegzukapern.
Genau, also den Luft abzudrehen.
Die Evolution der gegenseitigen Ausrottung.
Also insofern wäre jetzt nicht so tragisch. Man sollte es aber vielleicht irgendwie versuchen.
Man darf nicht so drüber nachdenken, sonst bringt es einen runter.
Na wieso? Ich meine eigentlich ist es ja nur die Frage, ob man die kompetitiven Energien der Menschen in diesen Bereichen konzentriert, wo sie halt irgendwie nicht dazu führen, dass sie halt einfach mehr Ressourcen verschwenden.
Na meine Hoffnung für eine zukünftige Gesellschaft war immer, dass wir von diesem kompetitiven Scheiß wegkommen und einfach jeder macht irgendwie seinen Teil.
So viel schlimmer kannst du es gar nicht machen. Guck mal, wie viele Leute jetzt unglücklich sind. Wir medizieren Unmengen an Menschen, damit sie einfach funktionieren können, was Code ist, für Klappe halten und zur Arbeit gehen. Das ist eine wahre Epidemie von Leuten, die ohne Drogen überhaupt nicht mehr Lust haben oder in der Lage sind, an dieses Scheiß teilzunehmen.
Aber das wird ja eher noch schlimmer, wenn wir jetzt auch noch externe Faktoren haben.
Nein, eben nicht.
Nein, wenn...
Weil klar ist, dass die Ressourcen finit sind. Dann gibt es in bestimmten Bereichen schlicht keine Konkurrenz. So, dann ist halt klar, dass man... Bei finiten Ressourcen gibt es natürlich...
Wieso gibt es da keine Konkurrenz mehr?
Lass mich kurz erklären. Dann hast du in vielen Bereichen, ist halt vollständig klar, dass es so was wie natürliche Monopole gibt. Und diese natürlichen Monopole müssen halt im Gemeinbesitz sein. Weil da gibt es halt keinen Grund mehr, das halt irgendwie dem Markt zu überlassen. Weil der Markt in der Regel nicht darauf hinarbeiten kann, weniger Ressourcen zu verbrauchen. So zum Beispiel so was wie öffentlicher Nahverkehr oder überhaupt gesamte Transportsystem oder so was wie Handel. Also ich meine, warum? Es gibt eigentlich keinen Grund für irgendwas anderes außer ein staatlich oder in unserem Gemeinbesitz befindliches universelles Amazon. Wenn du mal kurz drüber nachdenkst, ist es völlig schwachsinnig, dass es irgendwie mehr als ein großes Shopsystem gibt, was uns ja auch allen gehören könnte. Und was du denn darüber handelst, kann man...
Das ist ein fairer Computer, der keinen verarscht.
Zum Beispiel, gell?
Unsere Overlords.
Wenn man aufhört, dass immer in diesen Kategorien von da muss aber jetzt irgendwie der Markt unbedingt mitspielen zu denken, dann sagt, okay, den Markt brauchen wir vielleicht irgendwie, brauchen wir vielleicht ein zwei, drei Kategorien, wo halt Innovation noch notwendig ist, wo wir halt irgendwie schneller vorankommen müssen, wo halt wir die kompetitiven Energien brauchen, aber in vielen anderen Bereichen, die lange abgegessen sind und wo wir halt, also wo das Spiel halt fertig ist, gibt es halt irgendwie genau keinen Unterschied.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich glaube an Spiele, die fertig sind.
Ich auch nicht. Wo ich dran glaube. Wer sorgt denn dafür, dass Amazon weiterhin günstig liefert, wenn sie keine Konkurrenz haben? Kannst du auch andersherum argumentieren. Kannst du sagen, nur dadurch, dass es da eine Konkurrenz und den Markt gibt, ist Amazon so günstig, weil sie im Moment noch Leute haben, die sie rauskanten müssen aus dem Markt.
Ich meine, Amazon in zehn Jahren ist vollständig durchrobotisiert. Das ist halt niemand mehr.
Ja, aber das heißt auch, dass sie keinen Anreiz mehr haben, da nicht irgendwie Sachen drauf zu schlagen. Also hier noch ein bisschen kleiner Zuschlag für irgendwie.
Wir gehen doch auf eine Financial Singularity hinzu, wo nur noch zehn Individuen alle Geld der Welt besitzen und da kann man das Geld auch abschaffen.
Da müssen wir mal ein T-Shirt draus machen.
Und dann, ich glaube nicht an eine Welt, wo gewisse Spiele fertig gespielt sind. Die andere Movement für so Zero Sum oder kein Wachstum, da nennen sie sich Stable State Economy. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ich an so ein Stable State glaube. Ich glaube, dass es immer große Wägen und Veränderungen gibt. Weiß auch nicht, ob ich glaube, dass es da große Bereiche gibt, wo es überhaupt keinen Markt mehr gibt. Aber ich glaube schon, dass der Premium für Kooperation hochgeht und der Premium für immer nur Konkurrenz machen geht runter.
Ich meine, de facto ist es heute schon so. Wir haben heute in vielen Bereichen Monopole, wir nennen sie nur nicht so. Es gibt nur einen Second Hand Market, eBay. Es gibt, wenn du irgendwie Online-Shopping ernsthaft betreibst, also in dem Scale, wie er betrieben wird, gibt es eigentlich nur noch Amazon. Also es gibt zwar noch diese anderen Shops, aber die machen Fulfillment per Amazon, weil die sind halt einfach per Economy of Scale die größten. Es gibt irgendwie in jedem Land nur noch durch künstliche Regulierungen mehr als einen Telekommunikationsprovider. Es gibt da eigentlich auch gar keinen Grund dafür. Also wenn es halt der einzige Grund dafür ist, dass man Konkurrenz braucht, damit die nicht die Monopole-Situation ausnutzen, dann halt die Monopole.
Das hilft ja nicht.
Und es hilft nicht mal.
Es hilft nicht mal, genau.
Und zu sagen, okay, was spricht dagegen in klar definierten Feldern, wo die Leistung klar definiert ist, zu sagen, okay, das sind die Kosten und da darfst du halt irgendwie ein Prozent Profit draufschlagen und das war es. Es ist halt ein Stay-with-State. So ist halt irgendwie der Standard-Kosten-Rahmen. So halt irgendwie für deine 100 Megabit für zu Hause, wissen wir, was es kostet im Average. Und da darfst du halt irgendwie zwei Prozent Profit draufschlagen und das war es halt. Warum nicht? Was ist schlimm daran?
Das haben wir ja bei den Energieversorgern gemacht und daraufhin haben die in England nach der Zetscher die Regulierung eingekauft, weil sie hier keinen Profit erwirtschaften konnten.
Naja, aber es hat ja offensichtlich funktioniert.
Ja, für uns toll. Für die Bund nicht so sehr.
Naja gut. Wenn es halt Bereiche gibt, in denen halt Stabilität klar ist und wo klar ist, dass ein großes Monopol der effizienteste Weg ist, also der ressourceneffizienteste Weg, nicht der profiteffizienteste Weg, der ressourceneffizienteste Weg ist, das Problem zu lösen, sehe ich da kein Problem drin, ist irgendwie einfach auch zu sagen. Ich meine, gut ist halt natürlich irgendwie heresie, was der reine Marktlehre betrachtet, aber die ist ja dann sowieso irgendwann tot.
Na du könntest in der reinen Marktlehre sagen, dann machst du einfach die Ressourcen teurer. Warum passiert das eigentlich nicht?
Na du hast ja selber darüber geblockt, wie was für ein Scam diese Klima-Witz-Zertifikate hat.
Ich meine jetzt sowas wie Kohle oder Öl, warum ist das eigentlich nicht teurer?
Na ja, weil natürlich die großen Fördermonopole es halt hinreichend gut schaffen, die Staaten zu verarschen beim Verkauf dieser Lande.
Ich finde das aber eine sehr interessante Frage, weil das ja auf mehreren Ebenen dieselbe Frage ist. Am Ende, dass man sagt, wir sehen den Untergang kommen.
Regulatory Capture.
Wir sehen einfach, dass wir auf den Abgrund zureiten. Und da würde man auch annehmen, dass die Leute alle aus Selbst-Erhaltungstrieb versuchen, es zumindest aufzuhalten und ein bisschen länger zu machen. Aber nein, die beschleunigen noch vorher, weil sie glauben, wenn ich jetzt hier noch maximal Kohle raustrage, kann ich vielleicht mit der irgendwie bis zur Rente überleben.
Ja, wenn du eh glaubst, dass das nicht mehr abzuwenden ist, dann wäre der Game theoretisch richtig, wenn man sich nur als Individuum sieht, wenn man nur als Individuum überleben möchte und man glaubt, dass es eh nicht mehr abzuwenden ist, der Spiel theoretisch richtige Lösung wäre, noch reinzuholen, was reinzuholen ist. Und das machen jetzt auch alle.
Ja, und jetzt wende das mal auf den Klimawandel an.
Ja, das ist auch schlimm. Wir brauchen Narratives, die von collective ausgehen und Narratives, die davon ausgehen, dass man quasi versucht zu überleben mit 10.000 oder 100.000 Leute und nicht mit 14 oder 15 oder deine Familie und noch ein paar Leute dazu und irgendwo einen Berg und Waffen kauft. Wir brauchen Überlebungs-Narratives. Wir brauchen dezentralisierte Narratives. Wir brauchen Überlebungs-Stories.
Wir müssen weg von diesem Zombie-Apokalypse.
Ja, genau, wir brauchen Stories, die von 1000 und 10.000 Leute ausgehen, die Regionen und City-States. Ja, das ist alles schwierig.
Okay, dann haben wir ja die nächste Sendung schon geplant, ne?
Ja, ungefähr, ja.
Ist eigentlich ganz lustig, wie das so die Entwicklung aus den Frühzeiten der Menschen nachbaut, dass da irgendwie sich Dörfer bilden und dann Städte. Dass wir das jetzt schon für die Postapokalypse planen, lässt eigentlich tief blicken, oder?
Ja, gut, ich meine, die Frage halt, wie man Governance in großen Einheiten hinbekommt, ist halt eben immer noch ungelöst.
Und auch in kleinen Einheiten ist das ungelöst.
Na, je kleiner, desto praktikabler bist du auf bestimmten Unterkünften.
Na, weil du dann einen wohlmeinen Diktator hast. Das ist die beste Regierungsform natürlich.
In dem Augenblick, wo die Leute irgendwie die Probleme, die sich ihnen stellen, überblicken können, sind sie in der Lage, relativ qualifizierte Entscheidungen zu treffen. Wenn ihr System einigermaßen korruptionsresistent ist so. Aber in dem Augenblick, wo es halt nicht mehr so ist und der Abstraktionsgrad hart zunimmt, dann treffen sie umso häufiger schlechte Entscheidungen und das System wird anfälliger.
Ich glaube, das ist auch tatsächlich der örtliche Abstand, der deine Rolle spielt. Denn wenn du irgendwie der Bürgermeister im kleinen Dorf bist und du machst zu dolle Scheiße, dann kann dich jemand einfach umnähten mit dem Auto oder einfach abwählen. Das ist, also wenn ich jetzt mal von irgendwelchen Dörfern auf dem Land aus sehe, unrealistisch. Dass der Bürgermeister ist, der irgendwie von der anderen Partei kommt, ist cool.
Doch, passiert dir den Tag. Überall in den ganzen Kommunen sind so freie Wählerinitiativen und Nichtpartei-Bürgermeister die Riegel. Wenn du durch Brandenburg fährst, da sind halt in den kleineren Dörfern und so, findest du selten Dörfer, wo halt noch klassische CDU oder SPD-Bürgermeister sind. Sondern es sind halt ganz häufig so irgendwelche Wählergemeinschaften, die sich halt ganz lokal bilden und sagen so, wir wollen keine große Politik machen, wir wollen nur, dass da ein Typ sitzt, der ungefähr weiß, was er tut. Das ist ziemlich häufig.
Das ist ja gerade zur Hoffnung.
Oder auch nicht, wenn du Brandenburg näher anschaust und guckst, was da jetzt brennt.
Na gut, Brandenburg ist aber noch nicht so.
Oder Sachsen, oder?
Na ja, Sachsen ist ein Problem. So läuft's. Na gut.
So wollen wir nicht noch eine positive Endnote finden?
Ich scroll hier gerade, das ist ein bisschen schwierig in unserem Pet. Wir haben hier nur so relativ wenig positive Dinge. Tja, nee, also schwierig. Nee, das glaube ich ganze Pet ist nicht sehr positiv. So läuft's. Na ja gut, wir haben es ja auch State of the World genannt. Na gut, ja, insofern vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wir hoffen, wir haben uns nicht allzu sehr deprimiert.
Und jetzt hier keinen Selbstmord machen, wir brauchen euch noch.
Genau, wir versprechen euch damit, damit ihr euch nichts antun, versprechen wir euch, dass wir noch mehr Sendungen demnächst machen. Wir haben auch schon eine sehr imposante Gästeliste geplant. Hoffen wir, dass wir die bald umsetzen können.
Wir müssen jetzt nur noch die Terminplanung finalisieren.
Genau, die Terminplanung durchkriegen. Und falls es euch gefallen hat, da gibt es wie immer den Flatterbutton, auf den ihr gerne drücken könnt. Und dann vielen Dank an Rop für's hier sein.
Gerne.
Und für die positive Ausstrahlung.
Für die positive Grundausstrahlung, genau. Dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.